Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe von Raumzeit, dem Podcast der Gesprächsserie von der ESA und des DLRs. Und ja, hier in der dritten Ausgabe geht es wieder um ein ganz konkretes Thema. Wir befinden uns heute in einem Institut des DLR in Lampoldshausen. Und wie ich gerade gelernt habe, ist dieser Standort auch insofern etwas Besonderes, als dass er auch nur ein einziges Institut beherbergt. Konkret geht es hier um das Institut für Raumfahrtantriebe. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und mein Gast heute ist Ralf Hubertz. Hallo. Du bist ja Techniker an diesem Institut. Gibt es da eine offizielle Beschreibung, wie man das...
Ingenieur halt. Ich habe in Aachen in der RWTH Luft- und Raumfahrtechnik studiert und bin dann danach, nach dem Studium, direkt hier zum DLR nach Lampoldshausen gekommen. 1997 war das.
Ja, aus dem Namen des Instituts kann man jetzt auch schon ganz gut ablesen, worum es halt heute geht. Heute geht es um die fast sprichwörtlichen Raketenwissenschaften, die ja immer so ein bisschen in dem Ruf stehen, das Einzige zu sein, was wirklich kompliziert ist. Stimmt das eigentlich?
Ja, das, was wir hier testen, es mag kompliziert erscheinen, ist auch in gewisser Weise kompliziert, aber alles hat seine, ja wie soll ich das ausdrücken, Beherzbarkeit. Es ist keine Zauberrei in dem Sinne. Also es ist Technik, wie jeder andere auch, vielleicht ein bisschen komplizierter, aber man kann sie mit den Methoden und den Wissenschaften, die man sich erarbeitet hat, gut beherrschen.
Ja, Raumfahrtantriebe, also konkret hier geht es sozusagen um das, was brennt, das was Raketen in die Luft schiebt, das was Satelliten in der Bahn hält, was auch die Space Station sozusagen immer wieder auf Kurs bringt. Du hast jetzt schon erwähnt, RWTH Aachen, Ausbildung, als was genau hast du da gemacht?
Ingenieur für Luft- und Raumfahrtechnik.
Ingenieur für Luft- und Raumfahrtechnik. Das heißt, du hast im Prinzip gleich vom Studium an auch direkt Kurs ins All genommen?
Ja, eigentlich war das schon vor dem Studium so. Ich interessiere mich seit meiner Kindheit eigentlich schon für Raumfahrt. Das ging erst mit Astronomie los, aber dann bin ich so zielstrebig den Weg gegangen, dass ich dann nach dem Abitur direkt Luft- und Raumfahrtechnik studiert habe, beziehungsweise in Aachen ist das der Studiengang Maschinenbau, der sich dann nach dem Vordeplom vertieft in Richtung Luft- und Raumfahrtechnik. Und auch da kann man dann nochmal vertiefen in Richtung Raumfahrt.
Und warum muss es die Astronomie sein? Was war das Faszinierende daran?
Das Auslösende war damals, das weiß ich noch, wir hatten in der Grundschule eine kleine Bibliothek und unsere Lehrerin hat uns damals gesagt, sobald ihr lesen könnt, könnt ihr euch da ein Buch ausleihen. Und das Buch, was ich damals da in die Hände bekommen hab, was ich mir rausgesucht hab, das war aus der Serie Was ist was? Der Band 6, die Sterne. Und damit war es im Prinzip passiert. Das hat mich so fasziniert.
Gleich das erste Buch, ich muss sagen.
Ja, genau. Und seitdem ging das eher so erstmal in Richtung Astronomie die ersten Jahre, bis dann es 1981 mit den Space Shuttle-Flügen losging. Es war ja so eine Zeit nach den Apollo-Flügen. In meiner Kindheit, wo es keine bemannte Raumfahrt gab in Amerika und Russland wusste man damals noch nicht viel, da kam nicht viel an die Öffentlichkeit. Und erst 1981 dann mit den ersten Space Shuttle-Flügen ging das dann so richtig los, dass man am Fernsehen, dass ich mir Live-Übertragungen angeguckt habe, am Radio auch alles aufgenommen, auf Audiokassette damals noch, als man noch keinen Videorecorder hatte. Und so hat sich das dann weiterentwickelt.
Das heißt, du bist dann auch relativ schnell zum DLR gekommen, quasi mehr oder weniger auf direkten Wege?
Ja, erst mal Studium angefangen, halt Maschinenbau, Luft- und Raumfahrttechnik. Und dann hab ich noch eine zweite Schiene gehabt. Ich hab Leute kennengelernt, die eine Zeitschrift gemacht haben. Und da hab ich dann auch für geschrieben und konnte so dann quasi als Raumfahrtsjournalist auch ersten Kontakt zum DLR aufbauen. Also nicht so sehr über Studium, sondern über diese zweite Schiene, die ich da hatte. Das war ein Verlag, der nennt sich Raumfahrtimpfodienst. Den gibt's aber heute nicht mehr.
Ja, Raumfahrtantriebe. Darum soll's gehen. Wir wollen sozusagen jetzt mal überlegen oder mal anschauen, wie man die Erde eigentlich verlässt. Bisher war jetzt ja viel über Organisation, die Rede, wie man halt so Missionen plant. Aber wenn's dann halt ernst werden soll und man jetzt mal wirklich was ins All schießen möchte, naja, da braucht's halt erstmal etwas Kraft. Ist das eigentlich schwer, von der Erde wegzukommen?
Das ist enorm schwer, weil man kann jedenfalls den Weg, den man gegangen ist in den letzten 50 Jahren, ist es jetzt schon her, mit Raketen muss man halt die ganze Masse der Rakete nach oben hieven. Das heißt, man braucht mehr Schub als Gewicht beim Start, damit eine Rakete überhaupt vom Boden abheben kann. Das ist anders als beim Flugzeug, wo man die Flügel hat, die das Flugzeug dann in der Luft halten, die den Auftrieb auch erzeugen.
Hier gibt es sozusagen, Auftrieb muss alles hinzugefügt werden.
Genau. Und bei der Rakete, die dann ja auch die Atmosphäre verlässt, muss natürlich auch im Gegensatz zum Flugzeug der Sauerstoffträger, der sogenannte Oxidator, mitgeführt werden. Man kann nicht wie beim Flugzeug den Sauerstoff aus der Luft nehmen bei einer Rakete.
Warum nicht?
Man könnte es für die erste Antriebsphase, aber das wären dann horizontal startende Geräte, so ähnlich wie der Sänger, wo man eine Unterstufe baut, die mit luftatmenden Triebwerken funktioniert, aber das sind kompliziertere Wege. Die Rakete ist dann eher der, in Anführungsstrichen, einfachere Weg, den Weltraum zu erreichen. Und für die ein, zwei Minuten, die das dann dauert, um die Atmosphäre zu verlassen, das rechnet sich nicht. Da muss man den Oxidator, wie gesagt, mitnehmen.
Der Sänger, das ist nur so ein Konzept gewesen, oder?
Das war ein konkretes Konzept von unserem Standortgründer, von dem Eugen Sänger. Und der besteht aus einer Unterstufe, flugzeugähnlich, mit luftatmenden Triebwerken, die dann bis in etwa 30, 35 Kilometer Höhe fliegen würde, bis ungefähr Mach 7, also siebenfache Schallgeschwindigkeit. Und da dann ein orbiterähnliches Gerät, eine Oberstufe, absetzen würde. Die dann mit wieder Raketenantrieben ganz normal in den Weltraum fliegt.
Würde, hat sie aber nicht getan.
Das ist halt ein Konzept, was technologisch sehr anspruchsvoll ist. Es gibt da verschiedenste Arbeiten in den letzten Jahrzehnten. Aber es ist noch Technologie, die zu weit weg ist, als das realisiert werden könnte, auch finanziell.
Aber ist sozusagen nicht ausgeschlossen, dass das in der Zukunft nochmal eine Bedeutung haben könnte?
Das hoffe ich, dass das irgendwann mal so kommt, dass die Raketen ja zumindest, ich sag mal, für den bemannten Transport, dass das eine Phase sein wird, die man dann mal irgendwie überwinden kann. Mit dem Space Shuttle ging das ja schon in eine bestimmte Richtung. War leider auch zu kompliziert, sodass jetzt auch bei den Amerikanern die nächsten Entwicklungen wieder hin zu kapseln gehen. Aber das sollte, wenn nicht in diesem Jahrhundert, dann vielleicht im nächsten Jahrhundert verwirklicht werden. Also man redet da über sehr lange Zeiträume.
Das heißt, die klassische Rakete, wie man sie eigentlich von Anfang der ganzen Raumfahrtentwicklung immer irgendwie wahrgenommen hat, ist eigentlich immer noch das aktuelle Konzept.
Das war halt damals der schnelle Weg, in den Weltraum zu kommen. Es gab in den 50er Jahren Bestrebungen, auch mit Flugzeugen in den Weltraum zu kommen. Da kann ich die X-15 nennen, die auch schon über 100 Kilometer Höhe erreicht hat, hat 199 Flüge gemacht. Aber als dann der im Kalten Krieg, das losging, mit dem ersten Satelliten der Sowjetunion, mit Sputnik, hat man halt den schnellen Weg gewählt. Wenn man den anderen gegangen wäre, dann hätte es wahrscheinlich noch Jahrzehnte gedauert.
Aber 100 Kilometer ist ja eigentlich schon Weltraum.
Das ist Weltraum, ist aber noch nicht umlaufbar. Man muss immer unterscheiden zwischen Weltraum und Umlaufbahn um die Erde. Das ist auch jetzt zu sehen vor dem Hintergrund der Touristenflüge mit dem Spaceship 2, die vielleicht in zwei Jahren anfangen werden. Man kommt dort in den Weltraum bis 100 Kilometer Höhe, erreicht dort auch vielleicht für fünf Minuten Schwerelosigkeit. Aber man hat da oben dann in der Höhe quasi keine Geschwindigkeit mehr. Aber wenn man in die Umlaufbahn um die Erde gehen will, dann brauche ich eine Geschwindigkeit von 28.000 Kilometer pro Stunde. Und das ist der Unterschied zwischen in den Weltraum zu kommen und Raumfahrt zu betreiben.
In den Weltraum kommen und da auch bleiben sozusagen.
Richtig, Raumfahrt ist Geschwindigkeit.
Okay, 28.000 Stundenkilometer, das ist eine Konstante, oder wie?
Das ist für die niedrige Erdumlaufbahn die Geschwindigkeit, die ein Satellit-Raumschiff, eine Raumstation haben muss, um nicht mehr auf die Erde zurückzufallen.
Wie hat sich denn das so entwickelt? Gut, die ersten Feuerwerkskörper gab es glaube ich bei den Chinesen, aber dass man jetzt wirklich ernsthaft darüber nachgedacht hat, so eine gewisse Höhe einzunehmen. Ich denke, am Anfang wusste man ja auch noch gar nicht so richtig, was einen erwartet. Ich weiß nicht, wie konkret sozusagen die Erwartung schon war oder was man von unten überhaupt hat feststellen können, wie es denn mit unserer Atmosphäre und sozusagen dem Raumfahrt aussieht. Was war denn am Anfang überhaupt das Ziel?
Am Anfang der Raketenentwicklung stand natürlich schon das Ziel, irgendwann den Mond zu erreichen. Das war klar, aber die Raumfahrt an sich hat dann doch anders angefangen, nämlich für den Krieg, wie man sagen muss. Also die erste Flüssigkeitsgroßrakete der Welt war die A4, die dann ja V2 genannt wurde.
Und was kam da zum Einsatz bei dieser Rakete? Also ich meine, was war sozusagen die Idee, technisch?
Technisch war die Idee, wirklich eine Rakete zu bauen, die dann in der Endausbaustufe, dies wurde dann, glaube ich, A9, A10 genannt, auch mit mehreren Stufen dann auch wirklich den Weltraum und die Umlaufbahn und die Erde erreichen kann. Man hat einen Raketentriefer entwickelt, was damals für etwa eine Minute brennen konnte mit den Treibstoffen Flüssig-Sauerstoff und Alkohol. Und wie gesagt, die ersten Raketen flogen dann etwa nur 500, 600 oder vielleicht auch so weniger, 200, 300 km weit. Aber geplant war das mal von Werner von Braun, dass es weiterging. Und er hat ja seine Arbeiten dann auch nach dem Krieg in Amerika weitergeführt.
Ja, aber ich meine, welche Überlegungen stand jetzt, also welche technische Überlegungen stand am Anfang, wie man, also um es mal ein bisschen aufzufalten, ich denke, aber erstmal, man hat beobachtet, man hat gemessen, man weiß, wie groß die Erde ist, etc. Man konnte auch mit der Gravitation irgendwie schon rechnen. Man wusste denn etwa, welche Kräfte man entwickeln muss, um auf eine bestimmte Höhe zu kommen. Oder war das zu dem Zeitpunkt noch unklar?
Das wusste man, ja.
So, und jetzt geht man her und schaut sich an, was hab ich denn überhaupt für ein Besteck, was ist denn überhaupt in der Lage, diese Energie zu entfalten, um irgendwas, was eine bestimmte Masse hat, jetzt nach oben zu bringen. Woraus könnte man sich da bedienen? Ich meine, damals war ja auch noch nicht alle die Antriebsstoffe sozusagen fertig im Regal. Da musste man ja wahrscheinlich auch erstmal ein bisschen zusammenrühren.
Das war schon alles neu, was damals gemacht wurde. Und man musste sich ja dann überlegen, im Endeffekt, wie erreiche ich diese 28.000 km pro Stunde, um in der Erdumlaufbahn zu bleiben. Und da blieben dann nur Raketen- oder Raumfahrtantriebe übrig. Man musste dann natürlich mit Treibstoffen hantieren, die man ja damals einigermaßen im Griff hatte. Damals war flüssig Sauerstoff schon ein neuer Treibstoff, aber der Alkohol, den man dann verbrennt dabei, oder den man damals da verbrannt hat, das war schon ein zu beherrschender Treibstoff. Im Gegensatz heute zum Beispiel zu den hochenergetischen Antrieben, die mit flüssig Wasserstoff funktionieren. Das ist dann schon wieder eine ganz andere Technologie.
Also die A4 hatten Flüssig-Sauerstoff und Alkohol zusammengebracht. In welcher Form wurde das da zusammengebracht?
Die Rakete bestand halt im Wesentlichen aus den zwei Tanks, und die wurden dann, der Treibstoff wurde dann in die Brennkammer gefördert und da zur Verbrennung gebracht. Und wurde dann über die Düse ausgestoßen und beschleunigt, sodass dann ein bestimmter Schub entwickelt wurde, der dann die Rakete vom Boden abgehoben hat, weil dieser Schub ausreichend war. Man hatte also mehr Schub zur Verfügung, als das Gewicht der Rakete über den Start war.
Und was ist das Komplizierte daran? Muss man jetzt einfach nur die Ventile aufschrauben, und dann fuckt das Ding los?
Das Komplizierte daran ist, wirklich diese Verbrennung stabil zu gestalten. Das heißt, der Einspritzkopf, wie man diesen Treibstoff einspritzt in die Brennkammer, das ist schon ein hochkomplexes Verfahren. Und hier wird ja auch im Institut für Raumfahrtantriebe auch daran gearbeitet in unserer Forschungsabteilung.
Aber wie wurde das jetzt sozusagen bei diesem ersten Modell konkret realisiert?
Das kann ich so nicht sagen, das weiß ich nicht.
Aber worum geht es, dass man nicht zu viel Sauerstoff, nicht zu viel Alkohol, von Balben nicht zu viel ändert sich auch noch diese Zusammensetzungsmenge über die Zeit? Oder geht es darum, eher konstant dieselbe Menge abzugeben?
Das ist richtig. Man sollte, wenn man mit flüssig Sauerstoff arbeitet oder überhaupt mit Sauerstoffträgern, immer einen gewissen Überschuss vom Brennstoff haben. Das heißt, man fährt, um Fachberief zu benutzen, unterstöchiometrisch. Das heißt, es bleibt immer ein gewisser Teil damals vom Alkohol, heute vom flüssig Wasserstoff übrig, der nicht mit verbrannt wird, um auf der sicheren Seite zu sein. Weil wenn man höher fahren würde, mit höherem Sauerstoff-Oxidator-Anteil, dann würde halt übrig gebliebener Sauerstoff die Brennkammerwand angreifen. Was heißt, man bei Sauerstoff halt oxidierend wirkt und wenn kein Wasserstoff zum Verbrennen mehr da ist, sucht der Sauerstoff sich was anderes.
Oder im ersten Fall jetzt der Alkohol sozusagen. Ah, verstehe. Das heißt der Sauerstoff schnappt sich sozusagen den Alkohol in der Verbrennung und das gibt dann die Energie frei. Welche Energie wurde da frei?
Ich hab jetzt nicht die genauen Zahlen von der A4 im Kopf, aber...
Röstenordnungsmäßig?
Nee, weiß ich vorhin nicht.
Also ich meine, wenn man das jetzt so mit einer heutigen Rakete vergleicht, war das Pipifax oder kam da irgendwie auch schon eine ganze Menge raus? Man wusste bloß nicht so richtig zu kanalisieren. Eine vergleichsweise kleine Rakete, oder? Für heutige Maßstäbe.
Es war eine relativ kleine Rakete, ja, ja. Und ich weiß jetzt gar nicht die genauen Abmaße, da muss ich passen.
Das heißt, diese Arbeit an der A4 war sozusagen die Kernarbeit. Damit war sozusagen der Weg vorgegeben.
Damit waren die Grundsteine gelegt, um dann in den folgenden Jahren, Jahrzehnten, so lange hat es ja dann nicht mehr gedauert, zu versuchen wirklich in den Weltraum, in die Atomlaufbahn zu kommen.
Und was wurde dann noch weiter verfeinert? War das Prinzip jetzt schon so gut, dass man damit die ganzen nächsten Missionen hat fahren können? Es ging sozusagen nur noch um die Details, wie man jetzt diese Einspritzung regelt?
Man musste natürlich auch weiter suchen, wie man so ein Triebwerk verbessern kann, wie man mehr Schub rauskriegen kann aus so einem Triebwerk. Das geht einmal durch höhere Drücke und Temperaturen bei der Verbrennung. Das geht natürlich dann durch verbesserte Einspritzverfahren. Feinere Zerstäubung zum Beispiel des Treibstoffs und des Oxidators, damit diese Tröpfschleifchenbildung mehr Oberfläche da ist und es besser verbrennt. Andererseits aber auch zum Beispiel durch die Form der Düse, weil die ja die Strömung für die Treibstoffe vorgibt. Da kann man auch eine ganze Menge mit erreichen.
Wie sehen die also aus? Wie muss man sich diese Form vorstellen?
Das sind so in der Hauptform Lavalldüsen nennt sich das. Als Glockenform kann man sich das vorstellen. Da gibt es natürlich auch Unterschiede zu den Triebwerken, die man damals hatte, wo man nur vom Boden abheben musste. Und heutzutage dann auch Oberstufentriebwerke, die im Weltraum funktionieren müssen. Weil bei so einem Triebwerk ist es ganz entscheidend, wie auch der Gegendruck aussieht. Ob dieses Triebwerk gegen einen Bar am Boden ankämpfen muss unter Umgebungsdruck oder im Weltraum im Vakuum funktioniert. Raketentriebwerke oder Raumfahrtantriebe allgemein funktionieren im Vakuum besser als in der Atmosphäre. Weil halt dieser Gegendruck fehlt.
Ah, verstehe. Das heißt unten müssen sie sozusagen gar nicht mal nur gegen die Gravitation arbeiten, sondern sie müssen auch noch gegen die Atmosphäre arbeiten.
Ja, ein Triebwerk hat unter den gleichen Brennbedingungen zum Beispiel im Vakuum 10-15% mehr Schub als am Boden. Bei gleichen Betriebspunkten.
10-15%?
10-15%, ja.
Das heißt, die Düse, also wo sozusagen schon der fertig gemischte Treibstoff durchfließt.
Schon verbrannt ist.
Und auch schon verbrannt. Also verbrannt wird er sozusagen sofort nach Austritt der Ventile.
Er wird dann in der Brennkammer verbrannt. Und diese Brennkammer verjüngt sich dann zu einem sogenannten engsten Querschnitt. Und in diesem engsten Querschnitt herrscht optimalerweise Schalldurchgang. Da erreichen dann die Abgase dann schon Schallgeschwindigkeit und werden dann in dem Divergenten-Teil der Düse auf mehrfache Überschallgeschwindigkeit beschleunigt.
Warum ist jetzt ausgerechnet die Schallgeschwindigkeit da jetzt die Größe? Ist das Zufall?
Nein, dann ist das Triebwerk optimal ausgelegt.
Das hat sich so ergeben, das hat man einfach festgestellt. Das hat aber jetzt nicht mit Schall zu tun.
Nein, aber da macht eins herrsch, dass da im engsten Querschnitt die Abgaseschallgeschwindigkeit erreicht.
Und dann verstärkt sich das sozusagen durch diese Öffnung der Düse?
Durch den Divergenten-Teil der Düse werden die Abgase dann beschleunigt.
Und dadurch wird noch zusätzlicher Schub erzeugt.
Da Impuls ja Masse mal Geschwindigkeit ist, kann man über die Masse des ausgestoßenen Treibstoffs mehr Schub erreichen, aber auch über die Geschwindigkeit.
Ah, okay, verstehe. Das heißt, diese Formgebung ist ganz entscheidend für die eigentliche Kraft, die so ein Triebwerk freisetzt?
Ein Triebwerk ohne Düse hätte vielleicht nur, ich sag mal, wie man da um halben Schub, was es mit einer Düse erreichen kann.
Das heißt, das Ganze ist auch im Wesentlichen so Strömungswissenschaft, kann man sagen?
Das ist richtig, ja. Das ist richtig. Gerade bei den, wie gesagt, Unterschieden, die man hat, wenn ein Triebwerk am Boden funktioniert oder im Weltraum, wenn ein Triebwerk für Vakuum ausgelegt ist, kann es sein, dass es halt am Boden unter einem Bar zu Strömungsablösungen kommt an der Düse. Und das geht natürlich dann in den Wirkungsgrad ein, dass der schlechter wird.
Wie ist denn das so in der Geschichte weitergegangen? Also man hat jetzt sozusagen grundsätzlich erstmal eine Methode gefunden. Okay, wir nehmen entsprechende Komponenten. Wir strahlen die in so eine Brennkammer ein. Da gibt es dann eine Zündung. Da entsteht schon mal eine enorme Energie, die dann noch dadurch verstärkt wird, dass man eben geschickt den Strömungsverlauf von dem entstehenden Verbrennungsmaterial durch diese Döse hindurchschickt. Durchschickt, war das sozusagen schon die ganze Antwort, die man brauchte, um zum Mond zu fliegen?
Vom Grundprinzip her ja. Nur man musste dann natürlich dieses Konzept weiter verbessern, weiter verfeinern. Das tut man ja bis heute und das wird man auch in den nächsten Jahren und Jahrzehnten tun. Weil, wie wir vorhin gesagt haben, die A4 war ja eine ziemlich kleine Rakete. Und beim Mondflug, als man sich dazu entschlossen hatte, brauchte man natürlich starke Antriebe, um wirklich Masse, das heißt das Raumschiff und dann später auch die Mondlandefähre, wirklich bis zum Mond bringen zu können. Und deshalb mussten diese Triebwerke immer weiter verbessert werden. Auch zum Beispiel, wie schonmal erwähnt, mit anderen Treibstoffen.
Was wurde dann verwendet?
Da es bei einer Rakete in der ersten Stufe beim Abheben darauf ankommt, dass man möglichst großen Schub hat, hat man in der Saturn V zum Beispiel, wenn ich das als Beispiel nehmen kann, beim Mondflug in der ersten Stufe Kerosin und flüssig Sauerstoff verwendet. Kerosin deswegen, weil es eine hohe Masse hat und man damit hohen Schub erreichen kann. Und in den Oberstufen der Saturn V, in der zweiten und dritten Stufe, hat man dann flüssig Wasserstoff und flüssig Sauerstoff verwendet. Durch die geringe Dichte, die der Wasserstoff hat, hat man nicht so einen hohen Schub, aber die Geschwindigkeit, mit der die Treibstoffe austreten, ist natürlicherweise bei einer Wasserstoff-Sauerstoff-Verbrennung sehr viel größer als bei Kerosinsauerstoff.
Bei uns ist das natürlicherweise so?
Das liegt in der Natur der Treibstoffe. Das kann man ausrechnen. Wasserstoff-Sauerstoff gehört zu den hochenergetischen Treibstoffen, die eine theoretische Austrittsgeschwindigkeit aus einer Düse haben, die sehr viel höher liegt als bei Kerosin und Sauerstoff. Wie gesagt, die Oberstufen haben jetzt mit Flüssigwasserstoff und Flüssig-Sauerstoff funktioniert. Triebwerksgüte kann man nicht nur an Schub erklären, sondern sozusagen an dem spezifischen Impuls. Das heißt, wie lange kann man den Schub mit der gleichen Treibstoffmenge aufrechterhalten. Dabei ist Flüssigwasserstoff und Flüssig-Sauerstoff sehr viel besser als Kerosinsauerstoff und eignet sich daher eigentlich besser für Oberstufen als für Startstufen, die man am Boden zünden muss.
Jetzt müssen wir glaube ich nochmal ein bisschen darauf eingehen, wie sich eigentlich die Konstruktion der Rakete als solche entwickelt hat, unabhängig von dem eigentlichen, wie der Antrieb selbst funktioniert. Weil ich höre jetzt die ganze Zeit Oberstufen, Unterstufen, das kennt man ja sonst nur aus der Schule. Diese A4 hatte das ja nicht.
Das ist richtig, das war nur eine einstufige Rakete.
Die hatte sozusagen eine Stufe und wenn dann irgendwie alles verbrannt war, dann fiel sie nur noch runter. Und wann ist man dazu übergegangen, diese Antriebe in verschiedene Stufen aufzuteilen und warum?
Es war theoretisch schon vor Beginn der Raumfahrt bekannt, dass man mit einer einstufigen Rakete, mit normalen Materialien, quasi nicht in den Weltraum bzw. in die Erdumlaufbahn kommen kann. Das hat ein Mathematiker aus Russland schon gegen Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts theoretisch ausgerechnet. Das am besten ist, Raketen in Stufen zu bauen. Das heißt, man baut eine Rakete z.B. aus drei Stufen. Das ist das Optimale, was man machen kann. Und wenn die erste Stufe ausgebrannt ist, braucht man diese Masse, die die erste Stufe dann hat, nicht mehr mitzuschleppen, stößt sie ab und zündet die zweite Stufe. Das sind also quasi dann, wenn man so will, drei Raketen in einer. Und wie gesagt, dieses Konzept stammt schon aus dem Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts. Und als man dann nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg dazu überging, dass man die Erdumlaufbahn erreichen will, das war z.B. die Aufgabe dieses internationalen geophysikalischen Jahres 1957-58, in dem ja dann auch die Sowjetunion mit Sputnik I den ersten Satelliten in die Erdumlaufbahn gebracht hat.
Warum heißt das geophysikalisches Jahr?
Das war ein von der UNO ausgerufenes Wissenschaftsjahr. So wie es heute auch letztes Jahr z.B. das Jahr der Astronomie gab.
Und dann sind alle so aktiv geworden. Das heißt, es war im Wesentlichen eine mathematische Berechnung. Klar, wenn man Stufe abwirft, dann geht Ballast verloren. Muss man nicht mehr mitnehmen. Aber wie ist denn überhaupt das Verhältnis zwischen Bau, Rahmen, Material versus Antriebsflüssigkeit? Ich meine, im Wesentlichen, die Stufe verbrennt sich ja schon fast von alleine. Oder ist das so ein 50-50-Verhältnis?
Nee, das ist ganz anders. Wenn man nach diesem Stufenprinzip geht, kann man ausrechnen, dass man, um in eine Erdumlaufbahn, in eine niedrige Erdumlaufbahn zu kommen, eine Rakete braucht, die etwa zu 97 Prozent aus Treibstoff besteht. So einen guten Leichtbau haben wir aber heutzutage noch nicht. Dass man die Trockenmasse der Rakete so leicht machen kann. Allgemein hat man heute Treibstoffmengen an einer Rakete von etwa 85 bis 90 Prozent. Das geht so in der Größenordnung. Das reicht halt nicht aus, um einstufig in den Weltraum zu kommen.
Also 85 Prozent des Gesamtgewichtes.
Beim Start, genau, besteht aus Treibstoff.
Das heißt, 85 Prozent des Treibstoffes, der Rest ist. Und schon das schränkt das so sehr ein, dass es klüger ist, in einzelnen Schritten immer was von dieser restlichen Masse auch noch wegzuschmeißen, um dann mit dem verbleibenden Treibstoff und der verbleibenden Trockenmasse einfach loszuziehen.
Im Prinzip können wir froh sein, dass wir nicht auf einem Planeten leben, der vielleicht 20-25.000 Kilometer Durchmesser hat, sondern auf einem wie die Erde, die nur 12.750 Kilometer Durchmesser hat, weil auf einem größeren Planeten wären wir vielleicht gar nicht in der Lage, Raumfahrt zu betreiben, weil wir von dem nicht wegkämen. Die chemische Energie, die in diesen Treibstoffen gebunden ist, die man freisetzt in solchen Raumfahrtantrieben, reicht halt bei unserer Erde aus, um in den Weltraum zu kommen. Wenn wir vielleicht auf einem größeren Planeten leben würden, dann hätten wir vielleicht gar keine Raumfahrt.
Da haben wir Glück gehabt sozusagen. Oder wir hätten noch bessere Treibstoffe finden müssen.
Oder ist es so, dass es auf größeren Planeten vielleicht gar kein Leben gibt? Man weiß es nicht.
Gut, das werden wir dann hier noch in einem anderen Gespräch in dieser Gesprächsserie klären. Okay, das heißt, diese Grundlagen, dass man mehrstufig arbeitet, waren früh da. Das heißt, die ganze Entwicklung ging letzten Endes auch relativ schnell in diese Richtung. Und als man dann auf den Mond wollte und das Problem hatte, dass man extrem viel Zeug da hochfahren musste, weil da waren irgendwie Astronauten drin, da waren irgendwie Landeferien drin, tralala, ein bisschen was zu essen, braucht man ja auch noch und so weiter. Da kommt das eine zum anderen. Was musste da für eine Masse überhaupt in die Luft, beziehungsweise genau nicht in die Luft, sondern ins All bewegt worden werden?
Die Saturn V war in der Lage, eine Masse von rund, genau weiß ich es nicht, aber so um die 50 Tonnen Richtung Mond zu schicken, aus der Erdumlaufbahn heraus. Wenn man das jetzt mal vergleichen würde mit dem Space Shuttle oder der Ariane, wenn man dann wieder zurückgeht und nimmt die Nutzlastkapazität der Saturn V für eine niedrige Erdumlaufbahn, war die Rakete in der Lage, etwa 120, 130 Tonnen in die niedrige Erdumlaufbahn zu bringen. Eine Ariane V kann da gerade mal 20 Tonnen hinbringen. Das war also schon eine sehr große Rakete.
Und die hatte dann aber auch drei Stufen?
Die Saturn V hatte drei Stufen und dann kam hier noch das eigentliche Raumschiff dazu, was man quasi dann noch als vierte Stufe benutzen konnte, was man aber dann erst beim Mond brauchte, um in die Mondumlaufbahn zu gehen.
Was passiert denn eigentlich jetzt bei so einem Start? Ich weiß nicht, wir haben es ja schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, die Ariane, der ESA, das ist ja eine der erfolgreichsten Raketenmodelle-Serien, kann man ja eigentlich sagen. Der Raumfahrt, weil sie vergleichsweise wirtschaftlich da die Mengen ins All bekommt. Was ist in dieser Ariane an Antriebstechnik denn konkret drin? Also wie hat sich das sozusagen seit den frühen Zeiten, auch vielleicht über diesen Entwicklungszyklus der Ariane, es gibt ja mittlerweile die Nummer 5, bzw. auch noch viele Zwischenserien natürlich, aber ich denke im Wesentlichen dürften sich auch diese Antriebe jeweils mit der nächsten großen Version der Ariane mitentwickelt haben. Was hat sich da so über die Jahre hin entwickelt und was ist da so der Status Quo?
Wir hatten ja letztes Jahr, Ende letzten Jahres, den 30. Jahrestag des ersten Arianenstarts von der ersten Ariane 1. Und die ersten Ariane-Modelle 1 bis 4 waren noch nach diesem Prinzip der dreistufigen Rakete gebaut. In der Unterstufe, in der Startstufe halt mittelenergetische Treibstoffe, mit denen man viel Schub aufbauen konnte, die aber keinen hohen spezifischen Impuls haben, wie ich vorhin schon mal erklärt habe. Und dann auch in der Ariane 1 1979 schon eine dritte Stufe, die mit Wasserstoff, Sauerstoff funktionierte.
Das ist dann hochenergetisch. Und mittelenergetisch ist Kerosin?
Das ist zum Beispiel Kerosin, ja.
Okay, und die niederenergetische, also was bezeichnet niederenergetisch dann genau?
Niederenergetisch sind halt Treibstoffe, die noch weniger Ausstoßgeschwindigkeit der Treibstoffe haben. Also diese Unterscheidung zwischen nieder-, mittel- und hochenergetisch bezeichnet quasi die Ausstoßgeschwindigkeit der Treibstoffe aus der Düse, aus dem Triebwerk. Und da liegt Wasserstoff, Sauerstoff ganz oben und dann kommen mittelenergetische Treibstoffe wie Kerosin mit Sauerstoff zum Beispiel oder auch Hydrazin mit Stickstoffdetoxid, was den Vorteil hat bei dieser Treibstoffkombination, dass sie selbstzündend sind. Da braucht man keinen Zünder für, die kommen bei Kontakt. Wenn die Kontakt haben, zünden die selbst. Und dann gibt es ja auch noch die Feststoffraketen, die zwar viel Schub haben, aber auch wie gesagt nicht zu den hochenergetischen Treibstoffen gehören.
Ja, also wie war das jetzt bei der Ariane?
Ja, bei der Ariane, wie gesagt, die Baureihen 1 bis 4 waren noch die klassische Variante mit drei Stufen. Wobei man dann auch bei der Ariane 3 schon erste kleine Feststoffbooster benutzt hat beim Start. Die Ariane 4 war dann kombinierbar, für die verschiedensten Möglichkeiten anpassbar. Zum Beispiel mit zwei Feststoffraketen, zwei Flüssigkeitszusatzraketen oder jeweils vier oder auch kombinierbar mit zwei Flüssigkeits- zwei Feststoffzusatzraketen, sodass man das auf die Masse der Satelliten, die man transportieren konnte, ganz gut anpassen konnte.
Das heißt, es ging darum, für die konkrete Load dann auch den richtigen Antriebsmix zu finden, damit man nicht mehr als man jetzt braucht?
Genau, und das war der Erfolg der Ariane-4-Rakete, die ja bis heute immer noch die kommerziell erfolgreichste Rakete der Welt ist. Die hat 116 Einsätze gehabt, ist 113-mal erfolgreich geflogen dabei. Das ist eine gute Quote.
Und den Begriff Feststoff, der ist jetzt neu. Bisher haben wir nur von flüssigen Antriebsmitteln gesprochen. Was hat es mit diesen Feststoffraketen denn auf sich? Wozu braucht man die und was ist da so fest?
Generell, ich habe ja vorhin erklärt, dass man in der Startstufe, in der ersten Stufe hauptsächlich Triebwerke braucht mit viel Schub. Und man ist aber jetzt von diesem Konzept schon vor Jahrzehnten, zum Beispiel mit dem Space Shuttle hat das angefangen, ist man weggegangen und hat in der Startstufe, beim Zünden am Boden, schon Wasserstoff-, Sauerstoff-Triebwerke benutzt, die halt nicht diesen großen Schub erzeugen, um abheben zu können. Und deshalb brauchen Raketen, die in der Startstufe Wasserstoff-, Sauerstoffantriebe haben, zusätzliche Startunterschützung. Und da nimmt man bis heute generell die Feststoffraketen.
Warum hat man denn das so gemacht, wenn das nicht so dafür geeignet ist? Warum benutzt man in der ersten Stufe etwas, was nicht in der Lage ist, die Anforderungen der ersten Stufe zu erfüllen?
Das ist ganz interessant. Die Gründe liegen zum Beispiel darin, dass man auch aus Sicherheitsgründen, aus Zuverlässigkeitsgründen, wenn man zum Beispiel die Ariane 5 als Beispiel nimmt, möglichst wenige Triebwerke im Flug zünden will. Wenn man ein Triebwerk am Boden zündet, was man bis in die Umlaufbahn laufen lassen kann, hat man nicht das Problem, dass man im Flug ein Triebwerk zünden muss, was zum Beispiel dann nicht funktionieren kann. Weil die Kombination Flüssig-Wasserstoff, Flüssig-Sauerstoff so energiereich ist mit dem hohen spezifischen Impuls, benutzt man das dann schon am Boden und kann das fast bis in die Umlaufbahn laufen lassen.
Also es geht gar nicht so darum, dass es schon an der Stelle seinen Schub entfaltet, sondern es geht mehr darum, dass es schon mal brennt.
Richtig.
Das heißt, man macht die Kerze schon mal an, aber so richtig Power kriegt sie dann erst später, wenn sie dann auch wirklich benutzt wird. Aber um diesen eigentlichen spezifischen Impuls zu entwickeln, um wegzukommen von der Gravitation und auch Widerstand zu leisten gegen die Atmosphäre, setzt man dem zusätzliche Raketen. Also das sind dann sozusagen die Booster, deswegen heißen die so. Es geht darum, den ohnehin schon vorhandenen Schub einfach noch mal zu verstärken.
Die in den ersten Minuten halt die Startunterstützung zu geben. Rein rechnerisch gesehen wäre es sogar sinnvoller. Man könnte damit noch mehr die Nutzlast steigern. Das Triebwerk, wie zum Beispiel das Vulcain oder heutzutage das Vulcain 2 bei der Ariane 5 in der Hauptstufe, das erst zu zünden, wenn die Booster ausgebrannt sind und nur mit den Boostern zu starten. Aber da man, wie gerade erklärt, das ja nicht will, weil das zu gefährlich ist, man zündet das Triebwerk erst am Boden und erst wenn das richtig läuft, werden dann erst die Booster gezündet, um abzuheben. Man kann zum Beispiel, wenn das Triebwerk nicht gut anläuft, kann man das Triebwerk immer noch beim Hochfahren stoppen und die Booster nicht zünden und könnte die Rakete zurückrollen. Das Triebwerk ausbauen ist übrigens beim Space Shuttle schon des Öfteren mal passiert. Also bei 132 Flügen, die das Space Shuttle gemacht hat, ist das auf der Startrampe zum Beispiel schon 5-6 Mal passiert, dass da die, da sind es ja drei Triebwerke, drei Haupttriebwerke, nicht richtig gezündet haben und dass man dann wieder abgeschaltet hat und konnte dann ein paar Wochen später die Mission doch noch durchführen. Und gerade um bei dem Konzept zu bleiben mit der Ariane 5, wie ich gesagt habe, die Ariane 1 bis 4 war die klassische dreistufige Variante. Hier hat man dann halt die große Hauptstufe mit dem Wasserstoff-Sauerstoff-Triebwerk in der ersten Stufe mit der Startunterstützung der Booster. Und dann hat man im Flug in der ersten Variante der Ariane 5 in der Basisversion, wie sie 1996 zum ersten Mal gestartet ist, dann ein Triebwerk mit den vorhin erwähnten Treibstoffen Hydrazin und Stickstofftetoxid, die den Vorteil haben, selbstständig zu zünden, ohne Zünder. Das heißt auch wieder eine sichere Variante, um die Mission erfolgreich durchzuführen. Das war halt das Konzept der Ariane 5, dass man von diesen drei Stufen weggegangen ist und sozusagen einen 2 oder, wenn man die Booster mitzählt, einen zweieinhalb Stufe genommen hat.
Also der erste, der sozusagen schon unten gezündet wird, obwohl er alleine nicht reichen würde. Zusätzlich die Feststoffraketen, die dann den eigentlichen Schub entwickeln. Und die nächste Stufe, die dann erst später dazukommt, muss nicht gezündet werden, weil die entsprechenden Antriebsflüssigkeiten einfach von alleine zündet. Da weiß man einfach, solange die Ventile funktionieren, solange was rauskommt, dann brennt es auch.
So einfach ist es auch nicht. Das ist auch wieder eine Konzeption des Einspritzkopfes, die da auch doch mit beiträgt. Ganz so einfach ist es auch bei diesen Treibstoffen nicht, dass man nur Ventile aufmachen muss.
Okay, aber die Art und Weise, wie es dann geleitet wird, führt dazu, dass diese Entzündung stattfindet.
Genau.
Verstehe. Das heißt, Ariane 1 bis 4 war sozusagen technisch gesehen, was den Antrieb betrifft, die Iteration des selben Spiels. Nur, dass die Rakete größer geworden ist, in der Lage war, mehr zu befördern, mehr Kraft zu entwickeln, größer gebaut war etc. Und mit der Ariane 5 hat dann quasi eine generelle Änderung des Antriebskonzeptes eingesetzt. War die Ariane 5 da auch die erste, die das in dieser Form gemacht hat? Oder wer war an der Stelle der Pionier?
Das hat man sich im Prinzip vom Space Shuttle abgeguckt, wenn man es so sagen kann. Also das Space Shuttle war im Jahr 1981 das erste, was mit Sauerstoff, Wasserstofftriebwerken am Boden gezündet hat und dann mit Feststoffboostern dann abgehoben hat. Und dann kam die Ariane 5 und die Japaner haben das dann auch noch übernommen.
Naja, und jetzt ist das State of the Art?
Das ist im Moment State of the Art. Wie das weitergehen wird in den nächsten Jahrzehnten, das steht noch nicht fest, aber man möchte langfristig wieder von diesen Feststoffraketen wegkommen.
Jetzt haben wir diese Feststoffraketen als solche noch gar nicht so richtig erklärt. Also was heißt denn Feststoff? Was ist denn da so fest?
Der Treibstoff besteht nicht aus einem flüssigen Gas, wie jetzt Wasserstoff oder Sauerstoff, sondern aus einem Stoffgemisch, wo auch schon der Sauerstoff mit eingebaut ist. Und das härtet aus. Das ist im Prinzip erstmal eine Mischung, die angerührt werden muss, wenn ich mal so sagen kann. Und wenn das ausgehärtet ist, dann ist es halt wirklich ein fester Treibstoff, den man anzünden kann und der auch genau seinen Sauerstoffträger mit sich führt.
Also so ein bisschen so wie so eine Kerze.
Im Prinzip wie so eine Kerze, die man anzündet, ja.
Und was ist da drin? Also was rührt man da rein? Also Feststoffe, muss man dazu sagen, sind jetzt hier an dem Standort des DLR kein Thema?
Das ist hier kein Thema. Das kann man aus Umweltschutzgründen und auch aus Lärmgründen hier nicht durchführen. Die Feststoffraketen werden im Fall der Ariane dort getestet, wo sie auch geflogen werden, nämlich in Kourou in Südamerika, in Französisch-Guiana.
Ist das so laut?
Das ist richtig laut, ja.
Was macht das so laut? Also ich meine, was ist... Gibt es da einen Grund für? Also ich meine, es gibt bestimmt einen Grund für, aber...
Das weiß ich nicht, das haben Feststoffaketen so an sich.
Das heißt, das ist sozusagen so ein Mix, so ein Brennbeton irgendwie. Man muss irgendwie alles zusammenmischen, dann härtet das irgendwie aus, und dann ist das sozusagen drin. Und dann brennt es, ich meine, dann kann das ja auch nicht rauslaufen. Das heißt, das brennt sozusagen von unten nach oben weg.
Von unten nach oben, oder es gibt Feststoffaketen, die den Treibstoff so ausgeertet haben, dass in der Mitte ein Rohr reingetan wird, dass da so ein Loch drin ist, und das brennt dann von innen nach außen ab. Und dieses Loch kann man auch verändern. Da kann man einen Stern reinsetzen, statt jetzt ein kreisförmiges Loch reinzumachen, sodass man mehr Oberfläche hat, dann kann man mehr Schub erreichen. Also mit der Form, wie man es eingießt, kann man da auch schon einiges erreichen. Was natürlich dann bedeutet, wenn man mehr Oberfläche hat, dass der Treibstoff bei der gleichen Menge schneller abbrennt und die Raketen vielleicht nur eine Minute brennen, statt zwei Minuten. Das muss man dann dementsprechend beim Anfang, beim Beginn der Auslegung der Rakete berücksichtigen. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass diese Feststoffaketen von Mission zu Mission anders sind, das ist einmal festgelegt worden, wo die Rakete designt worden ist.
Aber Wunderkerzen sind ja auch noch so Feststoff. Nicht mit meinem schlechten Vergleich.
Wenn man so will, ja.
Ich versuche mir das gerade noch ein bisschen vorzustellen, was das so für eine Dynamik macht. Also gut, vielleicht...
Um vielleicht nochmal eine Größenordnung zu nennen, beim Start der Ariane 5 haben die Feststoffraketen 90% des Schubes und das Vulkan-2-Triebwerk nur 10%.
Die Feststoffraketen übernehmen 90% der benötigten Kraft.
Die Ariane 5 hat eine Startmasse von rund, je nach Mission, 750 Tonnen. Wie ich erwähnt hab, braucht man ja mehr Schub als Gewicht. Und wenn man den Schub mal auch in Tonnen angibt, dann hat die Rakete beim Start 1200 Tonnen Schub und 1100 Tonnen davon fallen auf die Feststoffraketen und nur etwa 100 bis 120 Tonnen auf das Vulkan-Triebwerk.
Wenn man jetzt sich jetzt mal diesen Start, ich meine, der Start, das ist ja auch so was Iconisches in dieser ganzen Raumfahrt. Wenn auch immer man irgendwie versucht, jetzt in Bild und Ton irgendwie Raumfahrt erlebbar und nachvollziehbar zu machen, dann sieht man immer so die Rakete da stehen und der Countdown läuft und tralala. Und dann macht es irgendwie Knallbumm, viel Rauch, Blitze und dann hat man nur noch die Rauchsäule. Das ist ja irgendwie was Feines. Aber was läuft denn da ab? Ich meine, der Start ist ja im Wesentlichen vor allem eine Frage der Antriebstechnik. Wahrscheinlich gibt es noch diverse Subsysteme, die in irgendeiner Form das Ganze natürlich einerseits kontrollieren und steuern und regeln, ganz klar. Und die vielleicht für sich auch noch in bestimmte Zustände gebracht werden müssen. Aber solange das Ding einfach noch auf der Erde ist bzw. noch nicht in dem Orbit, in dem es kommen soll, ist es ja eigentlich alles erstmal Raketenwissenschaften sozusagen. Also jetzt geht es wirklich um diese Verbrennung, die Koordinierte. Der richtige Stoff muss zum richtigen Zeitpunkt in Wallung gebracht werden. Wenn wir jetzt mal so diesen Countdown vielleicht für uns starten. Und wir nehmen jetzt mal die Ariane 5. Wieviel Sekunden bis zur Zündung haben wir noch, wo es sozusagen jetzt für die Raketentechniker schon interessant wird?
Also der Countdown beginnt ja schon mehrere Stunden vor dem Start. Im Prinzip dann, wenn es konkret wird, mit dem Befüllen der Rakete, mit den Treibstoffen, Flüssigwasserstoff und Flüssigsauerstoff. Wir haben die ganze Zeit immer über Flüssigwasserstoff, Flüssigsauerstoff gerade geredet. Man muss auch mal sagen, was das für Treibstoffe sind, mit denen man da umgeht. Zum Beispiel Flüssigwasserstoff hat eine Temperatur von 20 Kelvin, das heißt minus 253 Grad Celsius, damit der überhaupt flüssig ist. Also tief kalte Treibstoffe, im Fachbegriff nennt man das kryogene Treibstoffe. Und der Flüssigsauerstoff genauso bei 90 Kelvin, minus 183 Grad Celsius. Und die Rakete wird leer, also die Hauptstufe mit Flüssigwasserstoff, Flüssigsauerstoff, ist leer, wenn die Rakete zur Startrampe gebracht wird.
Wann beginnt der Countdown genau, also in dem Moment, wo die da steht?
Das sind dann je nach Rakete unterschiedlich mehrere Stunden vor dem Start. Beim Special sind es fast drei Tage vor dem Start, wo der Countdown beginnt, mit verschiedenen eingebauten Halteperioden, wo man nochmal Systeme überprüfen kann oder Probleme rechtzeitig korrigieren kann, dass man doch noch pünktlich starten kann. Und wie gesagt, mit dem Betanken der Hauptstufe wird das dann konkret. Es geht ja auch darum, dass diese Treibstoffe beim Triebwerk, jetzt im Falle des Vulkine 2, am Eingang der Turbopumpen auch flüssig ankommen muss. Die Leitungen sind ja erstmal warm, ich sag einfach mal Zimmertemperatur. Und wenn der Treibstoff dann anfängt, wenn der Tank, die Rakete betankt ist, lässt man die Treibstoffe dann durch die Leitungen vom Tank.
Wo sind denn die Treibstoffe vorher?
Die sind in Lagerbehältern rund um die Startrampe.
Unterirdisch?
Ne, auch oberirdisch.
So in normalen Tanks, wie man das so kennt.
In vakuumisolierten Tanks, damit halt diese Treibstoffe unter diesen Bedingungen 20 und 90 Kelvin gelagert werden können.
Die müssen auch noch gekühlt werden?
Nicht aktiv. Wir haben vakuumisolierte Tanks, genau wie bei uns am Prüfstand hier in Lampoldshausen. Und man lässt immer einen Teil des Treibstoffes abdampfen. Und durch diese Verdampfungsenergie wird der Treibstoff selbstständig gekühlt. Man braucht also keine aktive Kühlung.
Verstehe. Okay, das heißt so ein minimaler Anteil davon, das ist jetzt nicht viel oder verbraucht das schon auch viel?
Verdampft pro Tag. Bei uns am Prüfstand sind das bei einem Tank, der 600.000 Liter fasst, sind das ein paar Hundert Liter am Tag, die da verdampfen, damit der Treibstoff kalt gehalten werden kann.
Okay, also ein geringer Teil davon. Also nicht unwesentlich, aber jetzt auch nicht so, dass es groß ins Gewicht fällt im Vergleich zum Rest. Okay, das heißt, der Treibstoff ist sozusagen in diesen Tanks. Wo wird der produziert? Wird der auch vor Ort in Kuru produziert?
Der wird auch produziert vor Ort.
Das heißt, er wird da produziert, wenn er fertig ist, kommt er in diesen Tanks. Und dann puffen die sozusagen so vor sich hin und warten darauf, dass sie benutzt werden. Also verdampfen so ein bisschen so vor sich hin, damit sie einfach kalt sind und sie bleiben dann einfach kalt.
Die werden dann konkret schon...
20 Kelvin und es ist schon ganz schön kalt.
Das ist ganz schön kalt, ja.
So, und diese Tanks sind dann mit Rohren quasi mit dem Startplatz verbunden.
Auch wieder dann durch vakuumisolierte Rohre. Genau, damit möglichst wenig Verdampfungsverluste bis dahin geschehen, wo man den Treibstoff dann wirklich am Ende haben will, nämlich in der Rakete.
Aber die Rohre sind warm.
Die Rohre sind erst mal warm und ich kann jetzt zum Beispiel mal das Beispiel nennen, wie das bei uns am Frühstand abläuft. Die Rohre sind dann mit Helium bedrückt, mit 1,3-Bahnen, ein bisschen Überdruck, dass nichts an Luftfeuchtigkeit eindringen kann, was ja dann, wenn man das...
Also man schafft sozusagen einen permanenten Überdruck in diesen Rohren.
Überdruck und trocken ohne Feuchtigkeit. Und dann kann man halt dann die Treibstoffe da durchschicken und das dauert dann halt seine Zeit bis...
Warum nimmt man da Helium?
Man braucht immer, auch zum Beispiel zum Bedrücken eines Tanks, braucht man immer ein Gas, was einen niedrigeren Siedepunkt hat als die Flüssigkeit, die man bedrücken will. Sonst würde das Gas ja einfrieren und könnte nicht mehr zum Bedrücken funktionieren. Und deshalb kann man beim Sauerstoff, könnte man noch Stickstoff nehmen, aber beim Wasserstoff ist nur Wasserstoff selbst oder Helium möglich. Und deshalb verwendet man üblicherweise Helium.
Die Rohre sind unter Druck.
Ja, dann setzt man die Tanks unter Druck und macht dann die Hauptventile der Leitung auf und dann fließt der Treibstoff durch die Leitung Richtung Triebwerk. Und zum Beispiel bei uns am Prüfstand dauert das dann so üblicherweise, das wird in der Rakete nicht viel anders sein, ungefähr zwei Stunden, bis dann wirklich die komplette Leitung kalt ist, gefüllt ist mit Treibstoffen, dass es auch am Triebwerk kalt ankommt.
Und dann über den Verlauf der Rohre, das dann auch überall noch so ein bisschen verpuffen, um sozusagen diese Kühle da auch weiter herzustellen? Oder reicht es einfach nur, kaltes Material da reinzuschieben?
Man schiebt es rein und lässt es dann aber am Triebwerk wieder nach draußen laufen. Der Wasserstoff wird dann über eine Fackel in der Nähe der Startrampe oder auch bei uns am Prüfstand dann abgefackelt. Und der Sauerstoff läuft dann an einer anderen Stelle so weit weg, dass es da keine Probleme gibt, ins Freie. Das heißt, man braucht einen gewissen Prozentsatz des Treibstoffes, den man im Tank hat, fürs Abkühlen des Triebwerkes und der Leitungen.
Und das dauert dann zwei Stunden?
Diese Bedingungen müssen dann vor den Hauptventilen am Triebwerk, vor dem Einspritzkopf erreicht sein, dass dort die Triebwerke flüssig ankommen.
Das heißt, zwei Stunden wird abgefackelt bzw. in die Luft entlassen, bevor überhaupt ein Tropfen in der Rakete selber gelandet ist, in den Tanks?
Nee, ich meine jetzt am Triebwerk. Die Rakete wird befüllt. Und wenn die Tanks voll sind, dann kühlt man das Triebwerk ab.
Das Kühlen dauert jetzt so lange, bevor man überhaupt die Rakete erreichen kann. Okay, das heißt, Countdown, wo sind wir jetzt? Ich meine, wenn wir bei der Ariane bleiben. Space Shuttle hat einen längeren Countdown.
Da reden wir jetzt von, wenn die Stufe gefüllt ist und das Triebwerk abgekühlt ist, so von ein, zwei Stunden vorm Start.
Ein, zwei Stunden vorm Start. Dann ist der Tank voll oder da fängt er an voll zu werden?
Dann ist man üblicherweise mit der, hat man betankt und beginnt mit der Abkühlung, sodass man dann kurz vor Zündung fertig ist. Dass man die Abkühlkriterien am Eingang der Turbopumpen erreicht hat.
Das heißt, also es wird dann noch, da wird dann aber noch mal gekühlt. Da wird dann noch mal zusätzlich...
Die komplette Leitung bis zu den Turbopumpen vom Triebwerk. Beziehungsweise die Turbopumpen natürlich mit.
So, die Feststoffraketen müssen natürlich nicht betankt werden, weil die kommen sozusagen schon betankt. Das ist so das Werkwerfsprodukt der Raumfahrt eigentlich schlechthin. Oder ich meine, mit den Dingern kann man danach auch nichts mehr anfangen.
Das ist sozusagen... Beim Spaceship werden die wiederverwendet. Seit dem ersten Raumflug. Die kommen an Fallschirmen wieder runter im Atlantik, werden geborgen, werden dann gereinigt, wieder neu mit Treibstoff gefüllt und werden seit 30 Jahren immer wieder verwendet. Also sie bestehen aus einzelnen Segmenten, die man auseinandernehmen kann. Nicht eine Rakete am Stück, sondern die Segmente werden dann auseinandergenommen und werden wiederverwendet. In Europa macht man das aber nicht. Die Feststoffraketen sind dann auch nur einmal verwendbar.
Ah, weil es billiger ist, die neu zu bauen.
Richtig, es hat sich herausgestellt, dass Wiederverwendbarkeit nicht unbedingt günstiger ist als eine Wegwerfrakete.
Wie viel muss jetzt da so rein in so eine Ariane 5? Also von was für Mengen reden wir da jetzt eigentlich?
Ich kann das dann wieder vergleichen mit unseren Verhältnissen am Prüfstand. Wir haben hier einen Wasserstofftank, der fast 600.000 Liter und einen Sauerstofftank, der fast 200.000 Liter. Und damit können wir üblicherweise die anderthalbfache Brenndauer des Triebwerks erreichen, wie in der Rakete. Das heißt, dementsprechend wird das dann in der Rakete weniger sein.
Also 400.000 und 150.000, so das Verhältnis. Das ist schon eine ganze Menge.
Ja, und damit brennt das Triebwerk dann für etwa neun Minuten, neun und halb Minuten. Puh, dann ist das leer.
Okay, aber noch brennt es ja nicht. Jetzt haben wir überhaupt den Tank erstmal voll. Der Countdown steht auf zwei Stunden, bevor es richtig losgeht. Dann hab ich richtig gemerkt.
Dann kühlt man das Triebwerk ab. Und wenn man die Abkühlkriterien erreicht hat, dann kann man das Triebwerk zünden. Dann ist man halt, ich sag mal, vielleicht 10, 20 Minuten vor dem Start. Und geht dann, wie sie das immer so schön nennt, in die automatische oder synchronisierte Sequenz ab. Da kontrolliert dann wirklich konkret der Computer alle Abläufe, überwacht alle Temperaturen, alle Drücke in den Leitungen und meldet dann, wenn irgendwo ein Drucktemperatur nicht stimmt, dann kann auch schon mal der Countdown angehalten werden, mehrere Minuten vor dem Start. Aber wenn alles stimmt, läuft es dann durch bis Null. Und bei Null fängt dann an, das Triebwerk zu zünden.
Was heißt, es fängt an? Also man lässt zünden bzw. der Computer zündet?
Wir machen es hier auch wieder ein bisschen anders als in Amerika. In Amerika heißt Null immer abheben. Das heißt, da müssen die Triebwerke schon ein paar Sekunden vorher gezündet werden. Aber bei der Ariane, konkret jetzt auch bei der Ariane 5, öffnet sich bei Null das Hauptwasserstoffventil zum Triebwerk. Und damit beginnt die Zündung. Und so ein Triebwerk wie das Vulkan 2 braucht üblicherweise ungefähr 5 Sekunden, um richtig hoch zu fahren und den vollen Schub zu entwickeln.
Und dann wird es eigentlich erst ab.
Und nach diesen 5 Sekunden läuft das Triebwerk noch 2 Sekunden lang im stabilen Betriebspunkt. Muss also 2 Sekunden einwandfrei funktionieren. Und erst wenn das der Fall ist, wenn in diesen 2 Sekunden keine Anomalie auftritt, die der Computer merkt, dann werden die Feststoff-Raketen gezündet. Man geht also auf Nummer sicher, dass das Hauptstufen-Triebwerk, das Vulkan 2, ordentlich funktioniert, korrekt funktioniert, bevor man die Feststoff-Raketen zündet. Weil dann gibt es kein Zurück mehr, dann muss die Rakete abheben.
Was für Sensoren sind denn jetzt in diesem Triebwerk eingebaut, dass man solche Anomalien jetzt, also was kann man denn überhaupt messen?
Das sind alle Drücke und Temperaturen, die man üblicherweise in den Leitungen hat. Man braucht gewisse Drücke am Eingang der Turbopumpen am Triebwerk und natürlich die Temperaturen, wenn wir gerade davon gesprochen haben, Wasserstoff hat 20 Kelvin und Sauerstoff hat 90 Kelvin Temperatur, dann kann man so vielleicht mit 22,5 Kelvin das Triebwerk noch zünden oder mit 92,5 Kelvin, aber wenn man in den Bereich von 23 bis 25 Kelvin kommt, dann hat man schon wieder Gasblasen in den Leitungen drin und damit kann man dann nicht mehr zünden. Und diese Temperaturen zum Beispiel überwacht dann der Computer und würde dann auch konkret sagen, hier ist eine Temperatur verschritten und wenn das dementsprechend vom Programmierer so programmiert ist, kann man dann den Countdown abbrechen.
Also im Wesentlichen ist es eine Frage der Überwachung der Temperatur und des Drucks. Sonst noch was, was noch so überwacht wird?
Bei uns am Prüfstand ist es dann zum Beispiel so, dass auch noch Vibrationen überwacht werden, aber das natürlich dann erst, wenn das Triebwerk läuft. Wobei man üblicherweise am Prüfstand...
Ist das nur am Prüfstand so oder ist das auch bei der Rakete so?
Ja, es ist üblicherweise so, dass man am Prüfstand viel mehr Sensoren hat als im Flug der Rakete. Wir müssen ja zusehen, am Prüfstand, wenn ein Triebwerk einmal gezündet hat und läuft, wenn dann irgendwie eine Anomalie auftritt, dass das dann automatisch und sicher abschaltet. Wenn eine Rakete mal gestartet ist, brauche ich in dem Sinne, das Triebwerk nicht mehr sicher abzuschalten, weil ob ich das Triebwerk abschalte oder den Selbstzerstörungsmechanismus der Rakete vom Boden aus betätige, wenn das Triebwerk nicht richtig läuft, ausfällt, ist die Mission zu Ende.
Aber man will ja hier jetzt seinen Prüfstand nicht gleich jedes Mal in die Luft jagen.
Richtig. Ich verstehe. Natürlich muss das Triebwerk sicher abschalten im Nominalfall, wenn die Stufe ausgebrannt ist, bevor dann die Oberstufe zündet. Das muss natürlich dann auch kontrolliert und sicher geschehen.
Das heißt, gut, also Vibration mag oder mag nicht überprüft werden. Eine Ariane 5 ist vielleicht auch gar nicht so genau. Tatsache ist, der Computer muss diesen Prozess des Zündens extrem fein überprüfen. Wie permanent ist das? Also das ist sozusagen so ein permanentes Messen. Das ist nicht so, dass er irgendwie alle 10 Sekunden mal nachschaut, wie es so ist.
Ja, so in bestimmten Zyklen ist das dann schon. Aber das sind dann nicht 10 Sekunden, sondern üblicherweise vielleicht 10 Millisekunden. Also jede hundertstel Sekunde oder je nachdem, was da überwacht wird, kann das auch schneller und langsamer sein. Wie wichtig halt ein konkreter Druck- oder Temperaturanstieg dann wird.
Zumal die sich ja auch sehr schnell ändern.
Richtig.
Also, wir haben gelernt, die Amerikaner wollen bei Null abheben. Da merkt man mal wieder mal, welche Show-Qualitäten die Amerikaner haben. Das ist ja mehr sozusagen die Erwartungshaltung des Betrachters.
Der Countdown ist übrigens auch eine deutsche Erfindung. Der wurde erfunden in dem Stummfilm von Fritz Lang, Die Frau im Mond. Damals hat man überlegt, wie kann ich dem Zuschauer in einem Stummfilm klar machen, wann die Rakete abhebt. Da wurde dann für diesen Film konkret der Countdown erfunden. Wie macht man das? Wenn man von 1 bis 10 zählt, man weiß ja nicht, wann die Rakete abhebt, bei 8, 9, 10 oder was. Aber wenn ich runterzähle, jeder denkt, bei Null passiert was. Das ist auch eine Erfindung, die für diesen Film gemacht wurde. Und das wurde dann einfach...
Und ist bei dem Film dann um Null abgehoben, oder ist nur die Rakete gezündet worden? Ach, interessant. Das heißt, wieder einmal hat sozusagen die Science Fiction die Vorgabe gemacht. Man kann ja auch sagen, die wollten auch alle nur zum Mond, weil Jules Verne das halt mal aufgeschrieben hat. Das ist ja eigentlich immer so ein bisschen, also diese Science Fiction formuliert eigentlich die oder fast vielleicht auch, sagen wir mal, diese kollektiven Wünsche aller irgendwie zusammen, beschreibt das Fernziel, dann lesen das irgendwie alle Kinder und wollen dann irgendwie nichts anderes mehr machen in ihrem Leben, als diesen Traum Wahrheit werden zu lassen. Und so ist es dann auch manchmal so im Detail. Das heißt, Fritz Lang hat den Countdown erfunden und dann haben alle den Film gesehen, haben sich gedacht, oh, das ist ja eine super Idee. Tatsache. Aber trotzdem, in Europa geht es ja geordnet zu und da wird dann sozusagen um Null, also das ist ja auch nicht ganz unwichtig, also Null ist sozusagen diese Zündung der Triebwerke, wird quasi auch als der Moment angesehen, in dem es irgendwie losgeht.
Da wird das erste Ventil im Triebwerk geöffnet, dass dann halt Wasserstoff in die Brenkkammer fließen kann. Und wie gesagt, insgesamt dauert das dann 5 Sekunden, bis das Triebwerk hochläuft.
Warum braucht das so lange?
Weil verschiedene Ventile geöffnet werden müssen. Man muss, wie ich gerade gesagt habe, erstmal das Wasserstoffventil öffnen. Braucht dann eine gewisse Vorlaufzeit, dass sich die Brenkkammer mit Wasserstoff füllt, tut dann den Sauerstoff dazu geben, öffnet dann halt eine Sekunde oder so später das Sauerstoffventil, damit man, wie ich vorhin schon mal erklärt habe, diesen Wasserstoffüberschuss hat. Und dann läuft das Volcaintriebwerk ja auch in einem gewissen Zyklus ab. Zum Beispiel beim Volcaintriebwerk ist das der sogenannte Gasgeneratorzyklus. Man muss ja die Turbopumpen, die ich immer erwähnt habe, ja auch auf Drehzahl bringen. Insgesamt hat das Volcaintriebwerk drei Zünder. Man zündet, man bringt erst die Turbopumpen auf Drehzahl, zündet die Brennkammer und den Gasgenerator, damit mit diesem Gasgenerator dann die Turbopumpen weiter angetrieben werden können. Und dieser ganze Mechanismus braucht dann ein paar Sekunden, bis das Triebwerk auf volle Drehzahl gekommen ist und korrekt läuft.
Was dreht sich da? Also diese Turbolader, also das sind sozusagen Rotoren, die den Treibstoff dann in die Brennkammer verdichtet sozusagen, also die nochmal extra Druck erzeugen müssen.
Wir haben am Pumpeneingang Drücke von wenigen Bar und aus den Turbopumpen kommt man mit über 100 oder sogar 200 Bar raus. Das ist der Druck, den man dann braucht, um in der Brennkammer eine Verbrennung zu erzeugen. Man muss ja auch mehr Gegendruck zum Eingang der Brennkammer haben, als die Verbrennung in der Brennkammer erzeugt, sonst würde es ja zurückschlagen. Von diesem Druck liefern dann die Turbopumpen zum Einspürzen in die Brennkammer.
Das heißt, da existiert sozusagen der höchste Druck, um einfach mal auch den Tank zu sichern gegen die Verbrennung und aber auch um die Bedingungen zu schaffen für die feine Vernebelung und für die richtige Mischung der Gase. Was zündet die Gase konkret? Ist das sowieso am Herzen so ein Funkenflug zwischen zwei?
Im Falle des Volcanes sind das pyrotechnische Zünder auch, die dann die Brennkammer zünden und auch den Gasgenerator. Beim Oberstufentriebwerk Vinci, wo wir vielleicht noch zu kommen werden, ist das eine simple Zündkerze.
Simple ist vielleicht auch übertrieben, aber es ist halt eine Zündkerze. Pyrotechnisch, warum pyrotechnisch? Damit das irgendwie lange brennt, oder was?
Weil sich damit über längere Zeit die Bedingungen aufrecht erhalten lassen mit der Temperatur und dem Druck, um halt auch den gesamten Treibstoff, den ich hier drin habe, schön zu verbrennen.
Okay, das heißt, da sind wir jetzt wirklich bei der Wunderkerze. Also Wunderkerze wird gezündet, das Wasserstoff-Sauerstoff-Gemisch entzündet sich und dann geht's los. Die Turbopumpen arbeiten auf voller Pulle, erzeugen enorme Drücke und der ganze Druckwirbel wird dann eben durch die verschlungene Form der eigentlichen Düse noch mal weiter beschleunigt. Druck entsteht nach unten und über fünf Sekunden, also seit Countdown 0, seit der eigentlichen Zündung, waren jetzt zahlreiche Ventile damit beschäftigt, sich Schritt für Schritt zu öffnen. Das macht man wahrscheinlich auch hintereinander, um es besser kontrollieren zu können. Jedes Ventil hat es erst mal funktioniert. Ja, zack, dann kommen wir zum nächsten. So dass dann überhaupt erst mal die ganze theoretische Masse von Gas, das verbrennt ja, wie wir schon gehört haben, dann auch alles sehr schnell weg. Dauert nicht lange. Wie viele Ventile sind das so? Pro? Wie viele Brennkammern gibt es denn überhaupt?
Es ist nur eine Brennkammer, aber es gehören zum Triebwerk schon mehr Ventile. Da sind üblicherweise noch andere Ventile, die auch auf und zu gehen müssen. Das sind so konkret vielleicht um die 10, die da in den ersten 5 Sekunden schalten.
Okay, und die Ariane 5 hat sozusagen, es gibt nur diese, wir reden jetzt bei dem...
Kein Zweitriebwerk.
Es gibt nur ein Triebwerk.
Mit einer Brennkammer.
Da fließt alles rein. Wie viele Ventile waren das jetzt? So um die 10 Stück. Okay, über 5 Sekunden gehen 10 Ventile nacheinander auf. Alles hat super funktioniert. Mit einem enormen Druck wird jetzt verbrannt. Und dann stellt mal fest, hat ja alles ganz gut funktioniert. Dann kommen die Festkörper dazu, Feststoff-Raketen.
Genau, das Triebwerk, wir sind jetzt konkret bei 5 Sekunden. Das Triebwerk ist hochgefahren, funktioniert. Entwickelt da jetzt schon seinen vollen Schub. Die Rakete wird noch über die Feststoff-Raketen am Boden festgehalten. Die Feststoff-Raketen stehen auf Podesten, wo die Rakete festgehalten wird. Auch wenn der Schub sehr viel niedriger ist als das Gewicht, muss die Rakete ja trotzdem noch festgehalten werden. Dann läuft das Triebwerk noch...
Sonst würde er jetzt vielleicht einfach umkippen oder so, weil er einfach mehr Schub ist als man jetzt...
Die Rakete wäre jetzt ein bisschen leichter, dass sie nicht konkret umkippen, aber irgendwie muss die Rakete ja festgehalten werden. Sie muss ja auch zum Startplatz transportiert werden. Und sie steht einfach auf den Feststoff-Raketen. Solche Raketen wie zum Beispiel die Ariane 4 oder früher die Saturn 5, die keine Feststoff-Raketen hatten, wurden wirklich mit Klammern festgehalten. Wenn da die Triebwerke der ersten Stufe gezündet wurden, wurde die Rakete so lange mit den Klammern festgehalten. Und wenn die Triebwerke konkret richtig liefen, wurden dann die Klammern weggefahren und die Rakete konnte abheben.
Das ist ja auch so ein ikonisches Bild, was man im Kopf hat, diese Teile, die nach links und rechts wegspringen.
Das braucht man halt bei den Feststoffaketen dann nicht mehr.
Weil die dann einfach so zünden und dann einfach...
Das steht auf diesen Protesten und die werden dann auch wieder pyrotechnisch getrennt und dann kann die Rakete abheben. Wobei die Feststoffaketen wahrscheinlich so viel Schub entwickeln, dass die sich auch losreißen würden, wenn das mal nicht funktionieren würde.
Pyrotechnisch getrennt, das heißt, die eigentlichen Klammern verbrennen oder werden weggesprungen?
Das wird durchgeschnitten und dann ist die Rakete frei. Wie gesagt, wir sind jetzt bei 5 Sekunden, das Triebwerk läuft. Man lässt es noch mal 2 Sekunden laufen, um festzustellen, dass alles in Ordnung ist. Und dann werden die Feststoffaketen gezündet, mit einem großen Zünder, der in der Spitze sitzt und eine, ich weiß nicht, wie lange, 5 bis 10 Meter lange Flamme in dieses Loch von dem Festreifstoff reinschießt. Und dadurch werden die Feststoffaketen gezündet, die dann im Gegensatz zum Volcantriebwerk, was 5 Sekunden lang braucht, innerhalb von wenigen Millisekunden ihren vollen Schub erreichen. Das geht bei Feststoffaketen ganz schnell. Und damit ist quasi auch das Zünden der Feststoffaketen wirklich konkret verbunden mit dem Abheben.
Weil das ist der Point of No Return. Also da lässt sich jetzt kein Ventil mehr schließen. Wenn die Dinger einmal brennen, dann brennen die auch bis zum Get-Go.
Da gibt es ja auch keine Ventile in den Feststoffaketen. Das ist einfach nur die große Stahlhülle, wo der Festtreibstoff drin ist. Das ist unten die Düse, wo es rauskommt. Und wenn die einmal gezündet sind, die kann man dann nicht wieder abschalten.
Und die entwickeln jetzt 90 Prozent des Schubs?
Genau.
Das heißt, jetzt geht es los?
Dann geht es los, ja.
Und wie schnell ist sie dann so weg?
Die Rakete...
Man hat ja aber so ein bisschen so das Bild, sodass sie dann erst mal noch so einen Moment vor sich hin hofert da so ein bisschen so rumschwebt, bevor sie sich dann genauer überlegt.
Dieses Bild hat man dann wieder von den klassischen 3-Stufen-Raketen wie Saturn V und Ariane IV, die nicht so viel mehr Schub als Gewicht hatten, die dann ziemlich langsam starten. Dann gibt es üblicherweise Verhältnisse von 1,2 bis 1,3. Beim Space Shuttle oder bei der Ariane V hat man Verhältnisse Schub zu Gewicht von 1,5 bis 1,6. Und dann haut die Rakete schon ziemlich schnell ab.
Das heißt, es macht so bing und das Ding ist weg?
Startet ziemlich schnell und die Feststoff-Raketen vom Space Shuttle brauchen etwa...
Wie schnell ist das Ding dann?
Na ja, sagen wir mal so, ein 100-Meter-Läufer wäre wahrscheinlich auf den ersten 30, 40 Metern noch schneller als die Rakete. Das ist schon der Fall. Aber danach geht es dann wirklich nicht nur mit zunehmender Geschwindigkeit, sondern auch mit zunehmender Beschleunigung weiter. Weil der Schub bleibt gleich und die Rakete wird leichter, sodass die Beschleunigung zunimmt. Und so üblicherweise etwa nach, das ist jetzt auch von Rakete zu Rakete unterschiedlich, aber so ungefähr irgendwo zwischen 30 und 50 Sekunden wird man dann den Schalldurchgang erreichen, dass man schon Mach 1 überschritten hat.
Und dann ist man schon auch recht hoch.
Man versucht natürlich zuerst mit der Rakete aus den dichten Schichten der Atmosphäre rauszukommen. Die Erdatmosphäre hat in den ersten 10 Kilometern Höhe 90 Prozent ihrer Masse. Das heißt, wenn man erstmal 10 Kilometer Höhe erreicht hat, dann ist man schon mal ganz, ganz gut weit oben.
Das Schlimmste sozusagen hat man hinter sich.
Konkret wird die Atmosphäre dann so dünn, dass man auch später die Nutzlerspitze der Rakete abtrennen kann, so etwa dann bei 70, 80 Kilometer Höhe, dass es dann nichts mehr ausmacht.
Jetzt ist ja sozusagen alles gegenläufig. Das heißt, am Anfang ist es am schwersten, am meisten Schub wird generiert. Man hat am meisten Widerstand von der Atmosphäre. Man hat natürlich auch immer noch gegen die Gravitation zu kämpfen. So alles ist sehr schwerfällig. Man kommt hoch, aber mit jedem Meter und jedem Kilometer vor allem, die die Rakete nach oben kommt, verliert sie enorm an Gewicht, dadurch, dass der ganze Flüssigbrennstoff verbrannt wird. Beim Feststoff macht das wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viel aus.
Das ist die Hauptmasse der Rakete.
Die Feststoffe?
Ja, das ist die Hauptmasse der Rakete.
Ach wirklich? Ist das so viel schwerer als der flüssig?
Wasserstoff hat ja eine sehr geringe Dichte und flüssig Sauerstoff ist ungefähr, ich glaube, 14 Prozent schwerer als Wasser. Und der Feststreifstoff, der macht schon enorm viel aus von der Rakete.
Das heißt, nicht nur machen die am meisten Schub, sondern sie machen auch am meisten Gewicht, aber dann auch entsprechend am meisten Gewichtsverlust. Wie lange brennen dann diese Feststoffraketen?
Bei der Ariane 5 sind das etwa so knapp zweieinhalb Minuten. Dann sind die ausgebrannt und werden abgetrennt, fallen dann in den Atlantik und versinken dann im Meer.
Und dann ist auch schon eine sehr viel höhere Schicht der Atmosphäre erreicht?
Dann sind wir so in etwa 60 Kilometer Höhe, ja. Sodass man, wie ich gerade schon erwähnt habe, dann noch eine Minute später etwa so in 80 Kilometer Höhe schon die Nutzlastverkleidung abtrennen kann. Wie ich vorhin mal gesagt habe, alles, was man an Gewicht nicht mehr braucht in einer Rakete, weg damit. Und in 80 Kilometern Höhe ist die Atmosphäre so dünn, dass man die Nutzlastverkleidung abtrennen kann, sodass der erste Satellit oben frei liegt, halt in der Höhe, wo die anströmende Luftströmung nichts mehr ausmacht.
Aber vorher muss man sozusagen deshalb verkleiden, um einfach gegen die Atmosphäre zu schützen, weil die einfach lang schleift und potenziell jetzt einen Satelliten würde man hier oben so nackt reinstellen, da würde wahrscheinlich den Flug gar nicht überleben.
Das wird dann ziemlich heiß, ja.
Das ist im Wesentlichen Temperaturfrage.
Temperatur und auch Druckfrage. Das ist zum Beispiel auch so, dass Feststoffraketen normalerweise so gegossen sind vom Treibstoff her, dass die beim Schalldurchgang der Rakete zu der Zeit ein bisschen weniger Schub liefern als beim Start oder dann hinterher, sodass man die Rakete dann nicht unnötigen Belastungen aussetzt. Beim Space Shuttle ist es zum Beispiel auch so, dass man die Haupttriebwerke von 100 Prozent Schub auf ungefähr 60-65 Prozent Schub zurückfährt nach 30 Sekunden und dann kann man dann nach einer Minute wieder Gas geben sozusagen.
Warum ist das erforderlich?
Damit man wie gesagt nicht unnötig die Rakete belastet, wenn sie dann durch die Schallmauer fliegt. Das Verhältnis von Geschwindigkeit der Rakete zu noch vorhandenem Druck der Atmosphäre ist dann so, dass man möglichst schonend dadurch will.
Schonend, weil ihr sozusagen das Durchbrechen der Schallmauer einfach Vibrationen auslöst?
Das auch, ja.
Auch? Also weswegen im Wesentlichen? Also was ist sozusagen jetzt in dem Moment die Belastung, die eigentliche?
Wie gesagt, wenn dieser Staudruck zu hoch wird, dann wird es halt auch ziemlich heiß. Und eine Rakete, auch eine Raketenspitze, ist auch nur auf bestimmte Temperaturen ausgelegt.
Und jetzt Feststoff ist weg. Der Flüssigbrennstoff brennt ja die ganze Zeit.
Das Vulkan-Zweitriebwerk läuft dann noch weiter.
Und mit dieser einzigen Ausnahme, wo man beim Durchtreten der Schallmauer kurz zurücknimmt, brennt er aber ansonsten eigentlich konstant auf maximaler Power.
Auf einem Betriebspunkt, ja.
Und wie lange muss der noch schieben?
Das Vulkan-Zweitriebwerk brennt ungefähr neun Minuten lang, bis der Tank leer ist.
Den Namen haben wir jetzt tausendmal benutzt. Vulkan ist der Name des konkreten, in der Ariane eingesetzten Triebwerks.
In der Hauptstufe.
Und eins, zwei, drei spricht sozusagen für die einzelnen Stufen.
Nee, nee. Wenn ich von Vulkan-Triebwerk manchmal rede, ist das das Triebwerk, was in der Basisversion der Rakete vorhanden war, als die vor 14 Jahren zum ersten Mal gestartet ist. Und es hat dann eine Weiterentwicklung dieses Vulkan-Triebwerks gegeben, mit 20 Prozent mehr Schub. Und das nennt sich Vulkan-2-Triebwerk.
Das ist die zweite Generation.
Das ist jetzt seit acht Jahren im Einsatz, genau.
Aber das ist sozusagen nur diese eine Stufe.
Genau, die Hauptstufe der Rakete.
Gibt es überhaupt noch eine zweite Stufe?
Ja, wenn dann nach neun Minuten das Triebwerk ausgebrannt ist, wird dann diese Hauptstufe abgetrennt. Und danach zündet dann die Oberstufe der Rakete. Das war früher in der Basisversion eine Stufe mit Hydrazin und Stickstoffdetoxid. Diesen Treibstoffen, die sich selbst entzünden, mit dem sogenannten Estus-Triebwerk, was in Deutschland von der Firma Astrium entwickelt wurde. Was wir hier auch zum Beispiel testen in Lampoldshausen am Prüfstand P42. Und in der weiterentwickelten Ariane-5-Rakete, die heute hauptsächlich benutzt wird, das ist die sogenannte Ariane-5 ECA, da kommt das ehemalige Oberstufentriebwerk der Ariane-4 zum Einsatz, was auch mit Wasserstoff-Sauerstoff funktioniert. Es ging ja konkret in der Entwicklung darum, um nochmal darauf zurückzukommen, von der Ariane-1 über die Ariane-4 bis zur Ariane-5 jetzt, um die Nutzlast immer weiter zu steigern, um den gewachsenen Anforderungen des Satellitenmarktes gerecht zu werden. Übrigens eine interessante Geschichte, man könnte ja meinen, durch die ganze Miniaturisierung, die es in den letzten Jahren, Jahrzehnten gegeben hat, würden die Satelliten immer leichter werden. Klar, die einzelnen Bauteile werden leichter, aber dann sagen sich die Hersteller, hey, dann kann ich halt mehr Transponder draufstecken auf den Satelliten und kann noch mehr Leute bedienen mit Fernsehen usw. und kann auch mehr mit dem Satelliten verdienen. Und deshalb werden Satelliten nicht unbedingt leichter, wenn auch die einzelnen Bauteile leichter werden. Und dem muss man halt Rechnung tragen bei der Entwicklung der Rakete.
Das heißt, jetzt haben wir im Prinzip ja auch alle Komponenten der Rakete benannt. So eine Ariane 5 besteht im Wesentlichen aus der Hauptstufe. Das ist sozusagen unten der dicke Baumstamm mit dem Auslassrohr nach unten. Dann drum herum die Feststoffraketen. Wie viele sind das eigentlich?
Das sind zwei Feststoffraketen.
Dann diese Hauptstufe, wenn sie dann ausgebrannt ist, trennt sich einfach ab. Das heißt, sie wird auch mit ihrem Rahmen sozusagen komplett losgelöst. Die Feststoffraketen zuerst, dann die Hauptstufe. Danach gibt es eine zweite Brennkammer, die deutlich kleiner ist, nehme ich an, als die Hauptstufe, also die Oberstufe heißt es dann. Es gibt sozusagen Haupt- und Oberstufe. Und es gibt auch nur diese beiden. Und wenn die dann durch ist, dann wird die auch abgetrennt. Oder bleibt die einfach dran?
Zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo die Oberstufe zündet, besteht die Rakete quasi nur noch aus dieser Oberstufe. Und der Nutzlast, im normalen Fall einer Arianemission, dann aus zwei Satelliten. Und dieses Triebwerk läuft dann, je nach Missionsanforderungen, nochmal etwa 15 oder 20 Minuten. Und dann hat die Rakete die Geschwindigkeit erreicht, die man braucht, um zum Beispiel in den geostationären Transferorbit zu kommen. Das heißt, das ist ja so die Hauptmission, für die man die Ariane braucht, um Nachrichten, Wetter-Satelliten, Fernsehsatelliten in den geostationären Orbit zu bringen. Das können wir gleich noch erklären, was das ist. Dann hat die Rakete, wie gesagt, nach der Zeit, so viel Geschwindigkeit aufgebaut, damit die Satelliten bis in diese Höhe von 36.000 km in diesen geostationären Orbit kommen können. Und dann, wenn diese zweite Stufe dann abgeschaltet wurde, dann werden die beiden Satelliten abgetrennt nacheinander. Sodass die Satelliten dann antriebslos, mit dem Schwung, den sie haben, bis auf diese Höhe von 36.000 km kommen.
Aber nicht beide gleichzeitig, sondern erst mal der eine?
Genau, in Abständen von ein paar Minuten.
Das heißt, diese gesamte Launchphase hat insgesamt was? 10 Minuten gedauert?
25 bis 30 Minuten.
Was hab ich vergessen? Nach 2,5 Minuten sind die Feststoffraketen weg, die Hauptstufe 9 Minuten lang. Und dann die Oberstufe?
15 Minuten.
Die ist ja auch sehr gemächlich, aber die hat ja auch nicht mehr so viel wegzudrücken. Da gibt es keine Atmosphäre mehr.
Geringeren Schub oder längere Brenndauer.
Anziehungskräfte sind alle nicht mehr so krass. Das heißt, die kann so ein bisschen vor sich hinfackeln und macht sozusagen einfach so den Rest. Dann ist sie auch irgendwann am Ende. Oder ist sie dann schon am Ende, wenn die Satelliten abgesetzt werden? Oder brennt sie erst aus, wenn die dann auch weg sind, weil man die eigentlich noch die ganze Zeit braucht?
Die wird vorher abgeschaltet. Die wird abgeschaltet durch den Boardcomputer, wenn die programmierten Bedingungen, Höhe und hauptsächlich Geschwindigkeit erreicht wurden, die im Missionsprofil vorgegeben wird.
Und das ist dann so nach 25 bis 30 Minuten?
Genau.
Und dann besteht eigentlich die ganze Rakete eigentlich nur noch aus ihrer Nutzlast. Und ein bisschen Bordelektronik natürlich.
Bordelektronik, die Oberstufe und die beiden Satelliten, die dann abgetrennt werden.
Ja genau. Und wenn die Satelliten auch abgetrennt sind, dann ist eigentlich fast nichts mehr übrig von der Rakete.
Dann fliegt nur noch die antriebslose Oberstufe hinter den Satelliten sozusagen her, in einigen Kilometern Abstand.
Und was macht die dann?
Entweder hat man die Möglichkeit, das Triebwerk nochmal zu zünden, dass man die Stufe rumdreht, könnte das Triebwerk zünden, damit man diese Stufe zum Absturz bringt. Aber üblicherweise kann man das ja nicht machen, weil man keine wiederzündbaren Triebwerke hat. Und die Stufe bleibt dann einfach in der Umlaufbahn, bis sie dann irgendwann in der Atmosphäre verglüht und abstürzt. Das kann mehrere Jahre dauern, je nachdem, in welcher Umlaufbahn das ist.
Das heißt, sie wird einfach kontinuierlich von der Erde quasi zurückverlangt. Bzw. in der Restatmosphäre gibt es da nicht mehr so viel, oder im geostationären Bereich?
Die Satelliten werden ja in diesem geostationären Transferorbit ausgesetzt. Das heißt, man hat einen Orbit mit der höchsten Höhe in 36.000 km, aber der niedrigste Punkt liegt dann nur in ein paar Hundert Kilometern Höhe. Das heißt, die Satelliten müssen ihren eigenen Antrieb in 36.000 km Höhe nochmal zünden, um dann da oben zu bleiben. Die Raketenstufe fällt aber wieder runter auf diese paar Hundert Kilometer Höhe. Und dort habe ich noch so eine Restatmosphäre, dass die Stufe ein bisschen abgebremst wird und beim nächsten Umlauf nicht mehr ganz bis auf 36.000 km Höhe kommt, sondern ein bisschen niedriger. Und das geht so lange, bis man halt unten auf diese paar Hundert Kilometer Höhe angekommen ist und dann......wird es einfach immer mehr Atmosphäre und so viel Temperatur entsteht, in dem verglüht das gesamte Material. Wenn man erstmal auf 300 Kilometer Höhe gekommen ist, dann hat man innerhalb von einem halben bis einem Jahr dann den Absturz.
Okay, das heißt, man muss dann auch ein Jahr lang zugucken, wo das Ding irgendwie rumliegt, nicht, dass man da gegendonnert.
Das wird dann schon verfolgt, ja, alle größeren Objekte.
Das ist das Thema Weltraumöl. Das werden wir sicherlich auch nochmal aufgreifen. Richtig. Okay, aber jetzt haben wir im Prinzip so einmal die komplette Startphase der Rakete vollständig durchlaufen. Was macht man so als, also ich meine, das Bodenpersonal muss natürlich auch diesen gesamten Prozess verfolgen von unten. Gibt es eigentlich, welche Einflussmöglichkeiten hat man denn nachdem der Start, also nachdem die Feststoffraketen zugegriffen haben, dass klar ist, jetzt geht es einfach nur noch nach oben. Welche Eingriffsmöglichkeiten gibt es denn zu dem Zeitpunkt? Gibt es überhaupt noch welche oder kann man eigentlich nur noch sagen Detonation?
Da gibt es nur eine einzige Eingriffsmöglichkeit. Es gibt nur ein Kommando, was vom Boden aus nach oben geht. Sonst kommen alle Daten halt von der Rakete runter. Da werden auch wieder Drücketemperaturen gemessen und runter gesendet werden zum Kontrollzentrum, sodass man später den Flug auswerten kann. Aber ab dem Zeitpunkt, wo die Rakete abhebt, fliegt die Rakete komplett alleine durch ihren Boardcomputer. Das einzige Kommando, das man zur Rakete hochschicken kann, ist das zur Sprengung.
Was sind denn jetzt sozusagen die Herausforderungen, die jetzt hier besonders an diesem Standort, also wir haben ja schon mehrfach erwähnt, ich war Institut für Raumfahrtantriebe. Hier sind die Prüfstände, das heißt, wir sind ja hier von Wald umgeben. Das hat wahrscheinlich vor allem Lärmschutzgründe. Oder ist es deshalb, weil es hier so schön ist, oder weil hier alles so geheim ist?
Man könnte so einen Standort halt nicht, ich sag mal, in der Nähe von einem Flughafen aufbauen. Man hat ja auch die Abgase von den Triebwerken, die in die Luft gehen. Und wir haben natürlich konkret, wenn man das Thema Lärm anspricht, natürlich an den Prüfständen auch Maßnahmen zur Lärmreduzierung. Das heißt, die Triebwerke brennen nicht einfach so ins Freie, sondern da wird unterhalb des Prüfstandes werden wassergekühlte Rohre installiert, die dann die Aufgabe haben, den Abgasstrahl des Triebwerks abzubremsen, aber auch den Lärm zu reduzieren. Also da werden schon konkrete Maßnahmen ergriffen.
Aber was wird denn jetzt hier getan? Also was wird hier konkret entwickelt? Was wird hier konkret geprüft?
Also wenn ich meine Abteilung mal nehme, die Abteilung Versuchsanlagen im Institut für Raumfahrtantriebe. Wir betreiben hier die Prüfstände für die Europäische Raumfahrtorganisation ESA. Da kann ich als Beispiel auch mal die beiden größten Prüfstände nehmen, die wir hier haben, den Prüfstand P41 und P5. Am P41, das ist ein Doppelprüfstand, P41 und P42. Dort wird am P41 das neue Oberstufentriebwerk Vinci entwickelt, was vielleicht in sechs, sieben Jahren wird es noch dauern, bis es dann zum Einsatz kommen wird, bis es vollständig entwickelt ist.
Also Oberstufentriebwerk für die Ariane 5.
Für die Ariane 5 halt als Weiterentwicklung zur weiteren Nutzlaststeigerung.
Was heißt das Aktuelle?
Das Aktuelle ist das HM7B, was halt noch aus der Ariane 4 entliehen ist. Und am P42 direkt nebenan testen wir das ESTUS-Triebwerk, was am Anfang der Ariane 5 zum Einsatz kam, aber auch heute noch im Einsatz ist für die Mission des ATV zur Versorgung der Internationalen Raumstation. Da wird nämlich das ESTUS noch im Zusammenhang mit dem Vulkan 2 in der Unterstufe gebraucht und zum Einsatz kommt.
ATV, Automated Transfer Vehicle, das ist die Versorgungskapsel für die Internationalen Raumstationen, damit die auch immer was zu essen haben.
Das ist der europäische Anteil zur Versorgung der Raumstationen.
Aber was muss denn bei diesem ESTUS-Triebwerk noch groß geprüft werden, wenn er schon seit Jahren im Einsatz ist? Ist das da nicht abgehangene Technik?
Es ist zum Beispiel so, wie ich gesagt habe, die Treibstoffe bei diesem ESTUS-Triebwerk, Hydrazin, Stickstoff, Tetroxid, sind ja so, dass sie selbst zündend sind. Das heißt, man kann so ein Triebwerk auch mehrmals zünden, im Gegensatz jetzt zu dem HM7B-Triebwerk, das nicht wiederzündbar ist. Deshalb wird zum Beispiel auch ein Wasserstoff-, Sauerstoff-Triebwerk entwickelt, das Vinci-Triebwerk, was auch wieder zündbar ist. Aber um beim ESTUS zu bleiben, das Triebwerk war also in der Anfangszeit konkret wiederzündfähig. Aber man muss es dafür auch qualifizieren. Das heißt, man muss nachweisen, dass das funktioniert. Und für die ATV-Mission hat man das gebraucht, dass das Triebwerk dann wirklich zwei, drei Zündungen machen muss. Für die normalen Satellitenmissionen in den Jahren zuvor hat man das nicht gebraucht. Also musste man in den Jahren, bevor ATV das erste Mal geflogen ist, dieses Triebwerk wirklich zur Wiederzündung qualifizieren und das am Prüfstand alles mal durchspielen. Mit den entsprechenden Pausen zwischen den Zündungen. Es sind ja dann bei der zweiten Zündung, je nachdem wie schnell man die nach der ersten macht, ganz andere Bedingungen für das Triebwerk. Die Düse ist zum Beispiel heiß geworden, ist eine strahlungsgekühlte Düse. Und wie gesagt, das Triebwerk ist dann schon einmal gelaufen. Es sind ganz andere Bedingungen als bei der ersten Zündung.
Okay, das heißt, es geht hier sozusagen um eine Re-Evaluation der Technik, um sie sozusagen für einen anderen Einsatz dann auch zu qualifizieren. Das ist also jetzt kein permanenter Überwachungszyklus. Es ist schon so, dass wenn eine Technologie dann auch mal zu Ende entwickelt ist, dass sie dann nicht hier noch ihren eigenen Prüfstand braucht. Oder wird eigentlich immer alles permanent noch mal weiter geprüft und getestet?
Neben diesen Qualifizierungen ist es natürlich auch so, dass jedes Triebwerk, was in der Rakete zum Einsatz kommt, am Boden vorher einmal testgezündet wurde. Das konkrete Flugtriebwerk gilt für das Vulcan 2 genauso wie das HM7B und das Estus-Triebwerk und demnächst auch das Vinci-Triebwerk. Es fliegt kein Triebwerk in der Rakete, ohne vorher getestet worden zu sein. Es gab eine Ausnahme, die allerletzten Flüge der Ariane 4, das Unterstufentriebwerk, das man da hatte, das Viking-Triebwerk hatte man bis dahin schon über 1000 Mal gebaut. So oft war das im Einsatz so, dass man die letzten Flüge dann gemacht hat, ohne das Triebwerk zu testen, weil es quasi schon Serienproduktion war. Aber das war eine Ausnahme.
Und das hat auch funktioniert?
Das hat auch funktioniert, ja.
Das ist selten, oder, dass man in der Raumfahrt wirklich mit einem einzelnen Element so eine Zuverlässigkeit erreicht, dass man sagen kann, jetzt testen wir auch gar nicht mehr, das funktioniert sowieso?
Die Ariane-Rakete hatte von Anfang an vier Viking-Triebwerke in der ersten Stufe, eins in der zweiten Stufe und hinterher bei der Ariane IV kamen dann nochmal die Flüssigbooster dazu, die auch ein Viking-Triebwerk hatten, sodass man dann bei der Ariane IV in der stärksten Version neun Viking-Triebwerke pro Rakete hatte, plus dann noch das HM-7W in der dritten Stufe. Und wie ich schon gesagt habe, die Ariane IV ist 116 mal geflogen und dann kommt man schon auf die ganze Menge Triebwerke.
Das ist natürlich jetzt bei der aktuellen Technik, kommt man nicht auf dieses Stück zu halten. Von daher ist es wahrscheinlich nicht so.
Und weil Wasserstoff-Sauerstoff-Technologie zum Beispiel auch ein bisschen komplizierter ist als dieses Triebwerk von damals mit Hydrazin und Stickstofftetroxid. Das waren nämlich auch in der Unterstufe damals diese Treibstoffe.
Ok, also es geht sozusagen um Qualifikation, aber jetzt dieses Vortesten der konkret in der Rakete eingesetzten Triebwerke. Das wird dann aber auch in Kourou gemacht. Oder wird tatsächlich hier ein Triebwerk getestet, was dann verschifft wird?
Ja, die Triebwerke werden entweder hier getestet oder beim Triebwerkshersteller selbst, bei der SNECMA in Vernon nördlich von Paris. Wir kriegen ja zum Beispiel das Vulkan-2-Triebwerk dann angeliefert von der Firma SNECMA, um das bei uns zu testen. Oder auch jetzt das Vinci-Triebwerk in der Entwicklung. Aber im Moment werden die Flugtriebwerke selbst in Vernon abgenommen. Und wir haben hier zum Beispiel am Prüfstand P5 mit dem Vulkan-2-Triebwerk so alle zwei, drei Jahre eine ARTA-Kampagne, nennt sich das. Das sind so flugbegleitende Kampagnen. Da wird ein Triebwerk aus der Serienproduktion rausgenommen und dann mal auf Herz und Nieren getestet. So ein Flugtriebwerk wird ja dann nur in dem Flugbetriebspunkt getestet. Nur in Anführungsstrichen natürlich wieder. Und so ein Technologiebegleitprogramm kann dann dieses Triebwerk dann auch mal in verschiedenen Betriebspunkten testen, dass man mal sehr hohe, sehr niedrige Betriebspunkte testet. Man kann neue Komponenten testen oder man hat einzelne Komponenten weiterentwickelt, zum Beispiel Gewichtsreduzierungen. Und um diese Sachen auch dann wieder für ein Flugtriebwerk zu qualifizieren, hat man diese Kampagnen, die wir hier am P5 durchführen. So eine Kampagne läuft dann normalerweise so ein halbes bis ein Jahr. Und da werden dann 10 bis 15 Versuche durchgeführt.
Das heißt, hier gibt es sozusagen Forschung, hier gibt es Qualitätssicherung.
Auch ja, klar.
Also jetzt natürlich nach innen gibt es Qualität. Aber was hier konkret getan wird, ist quasi Qualitätssicherung. Der Triebwerkersteller macht sich mal einen rausnehmen, mal gucken, ob denn noch alles so ist, wie das auf der Bestellung stand. Nimmt man sich das Fax und dann misst man das mal durch. Aber es ist sozusagen auch neue Entwicklung.
Für neue Komponenten halt, nicht das Triebwerk.
Nicht das ganze Triebwerk, aber für bestimmte Aspekte.
Wenn ich an den P5 denke, sondern Komponenten. Was wir natürlich hier am P41 mit dem Winschi-Triebwerk haben, ist ein komplett neues Triebwerk, was dann auch bei uns hier, das ist jetzt schon 5,5 Jahre her, zum allerersten Mal gezündet wurde.
Und wer hat das konkret entwickelt?
Das Triebwerk ist auch von der Firma Snackma in Frankreich entwickelt worden. Die Komponenten des Triebwerks kommen dann wieder von ganz verschiedenen Herstellern. Zum Beispiel kommen die Brennkammern von Vulcan 2 und auch von Winschi von der Firma Astrium. Die Düse von dem Vulcan 2-Triebwerk kommt von Volvo. Die Sauerstoff-Turbopumpe von Avio in Italien. Und so ist das halt dann auch ein großes europäisches Projekt, auch ein so ein Triebwerk.
Aber hier wird auch geforscht sozusagen. Ist die Forschung hier jetzt so im Mittelpunkt, oder ist das eher ein Abfallprodukt der Prüfung? Wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Das gehört alles zusammen. Wir haben ja hier nicht nur unsere Großprüfstände zum Testen der areane Triebwerke, sondern wir haben ja auch einen Forschungs- und Technologieprüfstand, den P8. Und da werden dann auch Forschungsergebnisse in konkrete Hardware umgesetzt, die dann getestet werden kann. Da werden dann Triebwerke im kleinen Maßstab gebaut, die dann erst in Jahren in einem 1 zu 1 Modell getestet werden können, werden dann am P8 da getestet.
Das heißt mal so ein Miniatur-Raketchen.
Zum Beispiel im Maßstab 1 zu 4 oder 5 oder 10.
Das ist ja so ein Eisenbahnmodell H0.
Kann auch ein bisschen größer sein.
Bauernhausbrücke.
Kann auch ein bisschen größer sein. Aber so fängt man halt an, theoretische Technologien in Hardware umzusetzen und zu testen, bevor man dann in den großen Maßstab übergeht. Dass man dann lernt, neue Technologie zu beherrschen, bevor es dann konkret ins Große geht.
Wie lange muss denn so ein Triebwerk von seiner Neuentwicklung, seiner ersten, bis es dann wirklich in eine Rakete geschraubt wird und dann auch in den Orbit eintreten darf oder mithelfen darf, das zu erreichen? Wie lange, was ist so der Zyklus, wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Sind das ein paar Jahre?
Das kann man schon eher in Jahrzehnt oder mehr rechnen. Also bis, wenn eine Rakete mal konkret in Auftrag gegeben wurde bzw. von der ESA-Ministerratskonferenz beschlossen wurde, dass eine Rakete gebaut wird mit den entsprechenden Triebwerken, gab es ja bis dahin auch schon Vorlauf, weil es kann ja nicht entschieden werden, wir bauen eine Rakete, wenn man nicht schon einzelne Komponenten hat oder weiß nicht, mit welchem Triebwerk man die Rakete betreibt. Aber von diesem Zeitpunkt an dauert es fast 10 Jahre, bis so eine Rakete dann zum Erstflug auf der Startrampe steht. Und wenn man dann vielleicht rechnet, dass 5 Jahre Vorlauf für so ein Triebwerk auch notwendig sind, dann spricht man schon von Zeiträumen von 10 bis 15 Jahren von dem Zeitpunkt an, wo so ein Triebwerk mal angedacht wurde zum ersten Mal, bis es dann auf der Startrampe zum ersten Mal steht und in der Rakete zum Einsatz kommt. Das sind schon lange Zeiträume.
Aber die Entwicklung geht nach wie vor gut voran. Was ist sozusagen der Trend? Baut man eigentlich jetzt immer noch dasselbe, aber man fummelt so ein bisschen an den Details rum? Oder gibt es auch Überlegungen, am grundsätzlichen Prinzip zumindest einzelner Komponenten zu rütteln? Was denn zu dir?
Am grundsätzlichen Prinzip wird nicht gerührt, aber es wird im Detail vielleicht verbessert, dass man zum Beispiel die Turbopumpen vielleicht noch mit noch höherer Drehzahl laufen lassen kann, dass man das Gewicht reduziert, dass man natürlich in der heutigen Zeit auch immer darauf gucken muss, dass die Rakete auch preiswerter wird. Und im konkreten Fall des Vinci-Triebwerks sind wir halt dann auch dabei, die Nutzlast der Rakete noch weiter zu erhöhen. Wie ich vorhin schon mal gesagt hab, die Satelliten werden auch immer schwerer. Und ein großer Vorteil war es damals bei der Ariane 4, dass sie zwei Satelliten auf einmal tragen konnte. Und von der Ariane 1 mit unter zwei Tonnen Nutzlast ist man bis auf fünf Tonnen Nutzlast gekommen in diesen geostationären Transferorbit. Bei der Ariane 4, wie gesagt, von fünf Tonnen. Und das musste man mit der Ariane 5 dann weiterentwickeln. Die erste Ariane 5 hatte so 6,8 Tonnen. Wir sind mittlerweile bei der jetzigen Version, mit der ECA, bei zehn Tonnen. Und mit Winschi kommen wir an 11,5 bis 12 Tonnen Nutzlast in diesen Orbit, sodass man auch weiterhin immer zwei Satelliten starten kann. Die Hersteller dieser Satelliten können sich dann den Startpreis der Rakete teilen. Und dadurch wird man halt günstig.
Das heißt nur, dass durch die konkrete Neuentwicklung, den Austausch dieser Oberstufe, also der zweiten Stufe, erreicht man enorm viel mehr Nutzlast. Obwohl doch das Hauptproblem eigentlich ist, mit der ersten Stufe und den Feststoffraketen überhaupt erst mal loszukommen von der Erde.
Das ist richtig. Man muss erst mal von der Erde loskommen. Deshalb kann man nicht die Oberstufe beliebig größer bauen. Wenn man eine Oberstufe nimmt, die jetzt viel größer ist. Man könnte einfach daran denken, ich nehme mehr Treibstoff mit. Dann kann das länger brennen, hat mehr Schub und es gibt mehr Nutzlast. Aber das muss ich erst mal mit der Unterstufe bis da oben hinbringen. Irgendwo rechnet sich das dann nicht mehr. Ich kann so eine Oberstufe nicht beliebig groß machen. Dann muss ich schon wirklich an der Antriebstechnologie des Triebwerks ansetzen.
D.h. man versucht beim gleichen Gewicht mehr Power zu erreichen. Um auch in der zweiten Stufe die notwendige Kraft zu entwickeln. Sonst bleibt man ja dann bei zwei Dritteln. Und wie rechnet man das, ist es ja auch nicht.
Und wenn man das dann erreicht hat, wenn man so eine neue Oberstufe erreicht hat, dann kann man dran denken, wieder unten an der Rakete anzufangen, um wieder an der Unterstufe ein besseres Triebwerk zu bauen. So geht man immer von unten nach oben und wieder von oben zurück nach unten.
D.h. Winschi, wenn es denn kommt, würde dann quasi den Fokus wieder auf die Hauptstufe bzw. die Feststoffraketen lenken.
Wobei es dann auch so ist, dass irgendwann so eine Rakete auch ausgereizt ist, dass man nicht mehr viel machen kann. Deshalb gab es auch damals den Übergang von der Ariane 4 zur Ariane 5. Weil die Ariane 4 war so ausgereizt, man hätte jetzt nicht beliebig die Booster noch vergrößern können oder die Triebwerke noch stärker machen können. Irgendwo ist dann auch das Strukturlimit erreicht, wenn die Rakete immer höher wird. Deshalb muss man dann mal wieder zu neuen Konzepten übergehen nach einer gewissen Zeit.
Aber derzeit ist gar nicht so die Zeit der neuen Konzepte. Man ist glanzglücklich mit dem Ariane 5 Modell?
Seit etwa einem Jahr spricht man so von der Ariane 6, vom Nachfolgermodell. Es ist aber noch nicht konkret fest, wie diese Rakete aussehen soll. Ob man weiter auf diese Doppelstartfähigkeit setzen soll, oder man nimmt wieder eine Rakete, wo man wieder Einzelstarts machen kann. Wie ich gerade schon mal gesagt habe, die Doppelstartfähigkeit war damals ein großer Vorteil. Und Doppelstart bezieht sich jetzt darauf, dass beide......zwei Satelliten gestartet werden können. War damals ein großer Vorteil. Es ist aber auch manchmal ein Nachteil, wenn zum Beispiel die Satelliten nicht rechtzeitig fertig werden. Man hat einen Satelliten in Kuru liegen und wartet auf den zweiten, dann kann die Rakete nicht starten. Wenn man eine Rakete hätte, die nur einen Satelliten startet, aber halb so teuer ist wie die heutige Ariane 5, dann wäre man im Vorteil. Dann könnte man die Satelliten einzeln so wie sie reinkommen und fertig werden auch verschießen.
Und hätte keine Verzögerung und die gleichen Kunst.
Deshalb geht es der Gedanke an eine Ariane 6 auch zum Beispiel in die Richtung, dass man wieder kleiner wird.
Das heißt, die Ariane 5 muss immer zwei Satelliten haben?
Oder halt einen ziemlich großen, aber bei 10 Tonnen Nutzlast. Die Satelliten liegen üblicherweise so im 4-5 Tonnen Bereich. Wenn man dann schon wieder einen Satelliten hat, der jetzt 6 Tonnen hat, muss man wieder nur einen kleinen Satelliten finden, den man dazusetzen kann, mit 2-3 Tonnen. Das wird dann so in Kombinationen auch schwierig.
Man kann auch nur zwei nehmen. Man kann jetzt nicht mehrere reinschmeißen? Kann man da irgendwie alles so voll mit Satelliten machen?
Da müsste man dann schon wieder neue Adapter entwickeln, wo man die Satelliten dann absprengen kann. Üblicherweise ist die Ariane 5 nur mit Adaptern ausgerüstet, mit denen man zwei große Satelliten starten kann.
Sind denn jetzt außer der Ariane 5 auch noch andere Raketen im Einsatz?
Die Ariane 4 ist ja ausgelaufen damals, im Jahre 2003. Seitdem hat man nur die Ariane 5. Aber in den letzten Jahren hat man zwei weitere Raketen entwickelt, bzw. eine Rakete entwickelt, eine übernommen, sodass man dann auch die ganze Bandbreite der Satelliten-Nutzlasten abdecken kann.
Das muss ja auch nicht alles in geostationären Orbit zum Beispiel.
Richtig, richtig. Man hat also aus einer Feststoffrakete von der Ariane 5 eine kleine Rakete mit Namens Wege entwickelt, die nächstes Jahr zum ersten Mal starten soll. Die soll dann wirklich für Kleinsatelliten sein, die nur mehrere hundert Kilogramm wiegen und nur in niedrige Höhen von ein paar hundert Kilometern kommen.
Also so Kommunikationssatelliten?
Ne, die werden ja auch übt. Ja, zum Beispiel, oder halt für ganz andere Kunden. Man kann sich ja auch vorstellen, dass die Privatindustrie da auch mal Satelliten bauen lassen will, die nur ein paar hundert Kilogramm wiegen. Und die dritte Rakete dann dazu ist dann die Soyuz-Rakete der Russen. Das heißt, man hat in den letzten Jahren eine Startrampe gebaut in Kuru, von der aus die Soyuz-Rakete starten kann. Arianespass, die Betreibergesellschaft der Ariane 5 ist auch schon zu 15 Prozent an einer Firma namens Tarzan beteiligt, die die Soyuz-Rakete schon seit mehreren Jahren vermarktet. Die kann aber halt mit Satelliten im Augenblick nur von Baikonur in Kasachstan aus starten, von dem Startplatz, wo auch die Bebandenflüge stattfinden. Das hat dann den Nachteil, dass man bestimmte Satelliten mit dieser Rakete nicht starten kann, weil in vielen Satelliten westliche, amerikanische, europäische Bauteile drin sind, die ein Einfuhrverbot haben nach Russland. Wenn man diese Rakete von Kourou aus starten könnte, in französisch Guiana, das ist ja EU, könnte man auch dann solche Satelliten starten, die man von Kasachstan aus nicht starten kann. Und die Rakete hätte jetzt konkret wieder für den geostationären Transferorbit von Kourou aus mehr Nutzlast als von Baikonur, weil man mit Kourou diesen günstigen Startplatz fast direkt am Äquator hat.
Und nicht so viel Energie braucht, um nach oben zu kommen.
Weil die Erde sich am Äquator schneller dreht und man quasi schon mit einem gewissen Geschwindigkeitsvorteil startet.
Die Sojus-Raketen, also Sojus ist ja auch eine ganze Familie von Raketen oder ist das sozusagen auch nur ein Prinzip?
Es ist eine weiterentwickelte Rakete über die ganzen letzten Jahrzehnte. Es ist im Prinzip eine Weiterentwicklung der Rakete, die auch schon den ersten Sputnik nach oben gebracht hat und auch den ersten Menschen Juri Gagarin in den Weltraum gebracht hat. Eine ständige Weiterentwicklung, die aber so wie sie jetzt ist, seit 1967 im Einsatz ist, aber natürlich auch heute mit modernerer Computertechnik weiterentwickelt wurde.
Auch sehr zuverlässig?
Die Sojus ist sehr zuverlässig. Sie hatte zwar glaube ich vor zwei, drei Jahren mal wieder einen Fehlstart bei einem unbemannten Start, also nicht jetzt in der bemannten Raumfahrt. Aber diese Rakete und ihre ganzen Vorgängermodelle ist glaube ich schon über 1200, 1500 Mal geflogen.
Was ist das Prinzip der Sojus im Vergleich zur Ariane 4 oder 5?
Bei den Russen ist man immer mit Kerosin und flüssig Sauerstoff geflogen und hat dazu dann immer vier Booster benutzt, die man angebaut hat. Also Feststoff? Nee, auch Kerosinbooster. Die gleiche Technologie wie in der Kernstufe hat man dann auch für die Booster verwendet und hat dann noch eine zweite Stufe oben drauf gesetzt.
Also eher wie Ariane 4, so konzeptionell, als mit der 5 vergleichbar?
So ungefähr, ja.
Und dann zwei oder drei Stufen?
Das ist dann zwar nur zwei Stufen, aber mit den Boostern kann man das dann schon so sehen.
Das heißt, in Kourou wird jetzt sozusagen für die Sojus dann nochmal ein ganz eigener Startplatz gebaut?
Ja, da ist ein ganz eigener Startplatz gebaut worden, der fast so ähnlich aussieht, wie in Baikonur.
Weil das ist ja sozusagen auch voll auf die Rakete abgestellt, mit Versorgungsleitungen etc. Was man da dann wieder an Tanks und Kühlungen etc. braucht.
Wobei da auch ein interessanter Aspekt ist, man musste da auch sehen, dass die Sojus in Kasachstan, wenn sie von dort aus startet, die Sojus hat kein Selbstzerstörungssystem, wie zum Beispiel die Ariane 5, wo wir vorhin darüber gesprochen haben. Und wenn die Rakete nicht funktioniert beim Start, stürzt sie einfach in die kasachische Steppe ab und das war's. Für Kuru aus musste man das natürlich ändern, weil da brauchte man ein Selbstzerstörungssystem. Und so muss man auch so eine Rakete dann für solche Einsätze kann man nicht einfach so übernehmen, wie sie gerade konkret vorhanden ist, sondern muss sie auch wieder ein bisschen verändern.
Das heißt, die Rakete ist nicht für sich selbst autark, sondern sie steht und fällt eigentlich mit der Bodeninfrastruktur.
Auch ja.
Wann wird das dann stattfinden? Wann wird die Soyuz da starten, voraussichtlich?
Der momentane Termin ist, glaube ich, im Frühjahr 2011.
Alle schon ganz gespannt.
Die ersten zwei Raketen sind schon in Kuru und Nutzlasten für die nächsten Jahre sind schon in Auftrag gegeben. Ich glaube, Arianespace hat neuerdings auch schon 20 oder 30 Raketen bestellt, die dann in den nächsten Jahren verschossen werden können.
Vielleicht wollen wir noch mal einen kurzen Blick in die USA werfen, wo sich ja gerade auch eine ganze Menge verändert. Wir haben ja nun den Space Shuttle mehrfach erwähnt, sozusagen auch als Begründer dieses Prinzipes, den die Ariane 5 dann aufgegriffen hat. Was ist da die Raketentechnik sozusagen derzeit und wo geht da die Reise hin?
Das ist ein ganz interessantes Thema zurzeit, weil es da auch die letzten ein, zwei Jahre hin und her ging. Das Space Shuttle ist ja 1981 zum ersten Mal geflogen und noch vor zehn Jahren hat man gedacht, dass man das Shuttle vielleicht noch bis 2020, 2030 weiterfliegen wird. Wenn die Raumstation mal fertig ist, kann man die weiter versorgen mit dem Space Shuttle und wie gesagt, man hat gedacht, das kann noch 20 Jahre so weitergehen. Dann kam die Columbia-Katastrophe im Jahre 2003, wo die Columbia beim Wiedereintritt in die Erdatmosphäre auseinandergebrochen und verglüht ist. Wobei auch wieder sieben Astronauten ums Leben gekommen sind. Und danach hat der damalige Präsident George W. Bush das Shuttle-Programm für beendet erklärt. Natürlich nicht sofort, sondern mit Nachlauf. Man wollte den Fehler ausmerzen, der dazu geführt hat. Und dann zumindest die Raumstation fertig bauen. Aber sobald die Raumstation einmal fertig ist, sollte man dann um das Jahr 2010 rum mit dem Shuttle-Programm aufhören und dann wieder zurück zum Mond fliegen. Das war damals so das, was George W. Bush in Auftrag gegeben hat. Da hat sich halt das Constellation-Programm heraus entwickelt. Für die Rückkehr zum Mond. Durch die Wahl Obamas hat sich das dann jetzt ein bisschen geändert. Weil aber auch von der damaligen Administration zwar dieses Programm initiiert wurde, aber nicht genügend Geld dafür gegeben wurde. Man musste also Gelder aus dem Shuttle-Programm auch abzwacken, um da ein bisschen Anschubfinanzierung zu bekommen, die eigentlich nicht vorhanden war. Und dann kam dieses ganze Konzept nach der Wahl Obamas auf den Prüfstand. Da wurde eine Kommission eingerichtet, die dann die Empfehlung ausgesprochen hat, dass man mit den vorhandenen Budgets, die gerade bewilligt worden sind mit dem Constellation-Programm, es nicht schaffen kann, wie vorgesehen 2018 oder 2019 wieder zurück zum Mond zu fliegen. Das wird also mit Sicherheit zehn Jahre länger dauern. Vielleicht sogar erst in den 30er-Jahren möglich sein. Daraufhin wurde dieses Programm gestoppt. Erst vor kurzem Ende September wurde im Kongress beschlossen, im Budget der NASA für das Jahr 2011 eine neue Rakete vorzusehen, die die NASA entwickeln soll. Konkret ist aber jetzt bei Obama das rausgekommen, dass die NASA quasi nur noch für bemannte Raumfahrt außerhalb des Erdorbit zuständig ist. Man will also die bemannte Raumfahrt im Erdorbit, sprich die Versorgung der Raumstation, mit Gütern, Materialien, dann aber auch mit Astronauten, der Privatindustrie überlassen. Man will also jetzt den Schritt wagen, meint, dass die Privatindustrie so weit ist, dass man in ein paar Jahren die damit beauftragen kann, nicht nur Material, sondern auch Menschen zur Raumstation zu schicken. Und die NASA wäre nur noch für die Exploration, für die Erforschung des Sonnensystems jenseits der Atomlaufbahn zuständig.
Was bedeutet das jetzt für die Raketenentwicklung?
Das ist auch wieder so eine politische Sache. Raketenentwicklung allgemein ist nie losgelöst von politischen Zwängen. Man kann also jetzt nicht darauf hoffen, als Ingenieur oder Wissenschaftler zu sagen, ja super, ich habe eine gute Technologie, wir bauen jetzt das Beste, was es gibt. So ist es auch nicht. Die Rakete, die die NASA jetzt bauen soll, soll hauptsächlich auch aus Shuttle-Komponenten bestehen. Und zwar auch deswegen, damit man die Firmen, die in den letzten 30, 40 Jahren für Shuttle-Programm-Bauteile hergestellt haben, dass die weiter beschäftigt werden. Dass da die Entlassungen, die natürlich mit dem Ende des Shuttle-Programms kommen werden, möglichst gering gehalten werden.
Das wäre so eine Privatisierung, die diese Technologieart darstellt.
Man kann ja auch sagen, dass diese Technologie, diese Shuttle-Technologie mittlerweile so ausgereift ist, dass man so eine Sicherheit erreicht hat. Jetzt mal abgesehen von den zwei Shuttle-Challenger und Columbia, die da abgestürzt sind, das hatte dann andere Gründe. Aber diese reinen Technologien von den Triebwerken her sind so ausgereift, dass sie so sicher sind, dass man sie für den bemannten Transport benutzen kann. Zumal wenn man noch statt ein Shuttle auf die Seite an den Tank dran zu flanschen, wieder, wie es jetzt angedacht ist, eine Kapsel wie aus der Apollo-Zeit zu nehmen. Natürlich ein bisschen größer, 2,5 bis 3-faches Innenvolumen, damit man auch 6 statt 3 Astronauten transportieren kann. Zumal, wie gesagt, wenn man so eine Kapsel oben auf die Rakete setzt, mit einem Rettungsturm, der die Kapsel wegsprängen kann oder wegziehen kann, wenn so eine Rakete mal explodiert, was mit dem Shuttle halt damals nicht möglich ist. Deshalb sage ich, dass diese Antriebstechnologie ausgereift ist, auch wenn damals die Challenger-Explosion an der Feststoffrakete lag, die da einen defekten Dichtungsring hatte. Wenn so was passieren würde mit einer Kapsel oben drauf, würden die Astronauten nicht sterben. Das ist der Unterschied.
Ah ja, weil das woanders stattfindet.
Weil, wenn man ein Rettungssystem hat, das gut genug ist, so eine Rettungsrakete, die die Kapsel fortschleudern kann in so einem Fall, dann kann man schnell genug von so einer Explosion wegkommen. Die Russen haben übrigens einmal so eine Rettungsrakete gebraucht. 1983 ist eine Soyuz-Rakete auf der Startrampe, hat angefangen, Feuer zu fangen und ist dann explodiert. Aber bevor die Rakete explodiert ist, hat das Rettungssystem das automatisch schon gemerkt, weil das schon scharf war, weil die Rakete ja auch schon betankt war kurz vor dem Start und hat nicht im Flug, sondern auf der Startrampe, ich glaube, das war 60, 90 Sekunden vor dem Start, die ganze Soyuz-Kapsel dann weggeschleudert. Die Astronauten sind dann 5, 6 km entfernt von der Startrampe, zwar ein bisschen durchgeschüttelt, aber sicher gelandet am Fallschirm und konnten halbes Jahr später dann ihre Mission trotzdem absolvieren. Das ist das einzige Mal, dass so eine Rettungsrakete gebraucht wurde.
Aber dafür war es ja auch dann gedacht.
Genau, hat funktioniert.
Aber welche Raketen setzen denn jetzt die Amerikaner derzeit ein, um selber Satelliten zu starten?
Die Amerikaner, also die NASA selbst hat ja nur das Space Shuttle, das ist dann im Prinzip auch schon immer Privatindustrie gewesen, aber halt große Raumfahrtfirmen und nicht kleinere Raumfahrtfirmen, wie man jetzt so andenkt. Das sind dann Boeing mit der Delta IV Rakete und Lockheed Martin mit der Atlas V Rakete, die natürlich dann auch auf dem kommerziellen Markt Konkurrenten der Ariane V sind. Wobei die Delta IV ein bisschen weniger, die macht im Moment nur nationale und militär Nutzlasten und steht quasi für den kommerziellen Markt nicht zur Verfügung.
Und konzeptionell, wie stehen die da? Also sind die jetzt eher auch wie die Ariane IV und die Soyuz gebaut oder auch eher an diesem Space Shuttle Ariane V?
Das ist auch eine ganz interessante Sache, gerade bei der Delta IV. Ich habe ja gesagt vorhin, dass man bei Wasserstoff-Sauerstoff-Triebwerken in der Erststufe diese Feststoffraketen zur Startunterstützung braucht. Bei der Delta IV hat man es zum ersten Mal geschafft, eine komplett reine Wasserstoff-Sauerstoff-Rakete zu bauen. Man nimmt also quasi, wenn man sich das vorstellt, die Hauptstufe nochmal rechts und links als Booster daneben. Man hat aber dann ein Triebwerk entwickelt, das dreimal so viel Schub hat wie das Vulkan II. Wenn man davon dann drei Triebwerke benutzt in der ersten Stufe, hat man auch wieder Schub genug, um abzuheben. Diese Rakete startet aber ähnlich langsam wie die Ariane IV oder die Saturn V damals. Das ist dann wirklich ein quälend langsames Abheben.
Das heißt, schöne Zeitlupe dann?
Das ist fast Zeitlupe, das ist richtig. Das ist zum ersten Mal, dass man nur mit Wasserstoff-Sauerstoff abhebt bei der Delta IV Rakete. Und die Oberstufe ist dann auch noch mal Wasserstoff-Sauerstoff, sodass man wirklich eine reine Wasserstoff-Sauerstoff-Rakete hat.
Das ist ja eigentlich auch ein Vorteil, wenn man da nur eine einzige Technologie hat. Dann kann man ja auch alles doppelt verwenden. Tanks und Leute und Experten etc.
Aber man muss es halt auch schaffen, aus diesem Triebwerk genügend Schub rauszukriegen. Das kann man, wie ich schon mal kurz angerissen habe, entweder über den Druck machen, dass man den Druck in der Brennkammer erhöht, dass man die Verbrennung höher oder besser macht. Die Amerikaner sind aber da einen anderen Weg gegangen. Das heißt, man hat hier bei Brennkammerdrücken, die noch unter dem von dem Vulkan zwei Triebwerke liegen, trotzdem so viel Schub, weil man mehr durchs Triebwerk durchsetzt. Man setzt dort die dreifache Menge an Treibstoff durch und erreicht dadurch quasi den höheren Schub. Man macht das also über die Masse, die man ausstößt?
Jetzt müssen wir, glaube ich, langsam auch mal zum Abschluss kommen. Wir haben jetzt viel über die Raketen selbst gesprochen, die die Erde verlassen. Raumfahrtantriebe ist natürlich ein sehr viel allgemeinerer Begriff. Das setzt sich ja sozusagen auch im Orbit fort. Wir haben ja immer wieder erwähnt, man fliegt da oben rum, aber hier hat man Restatmosphäre und überhaupt die Erde saugt die ganze Zeit mit ihrer Gravitation an allem. Es gibt Steuerungen, die gemacht werden müssen. Diese Satelliten, die haben ja auch alle noch mal kleinere Raketchen, mit denen sie sich quasi in ihrer stabilen Position halten bzw. diese überhaupt erstmal finden. Was kommt denn da überhaupt zum Einsatz? Das sind ja sehr viel kleinere Module, die beileibe nicht so viel Energie. Nehmen wir die überhaupt ernst, als richtiger Raketenwissenschaftler?
Klar, wenn man an Raketentriebwerke denkt, denkt man immer an diese großen, riesigen Raketentriebwerke mit richtig viel Power. Aber auch diese kleinen Triebwerke haben es in gewisser Weise in sich. Da geht es um ganz andere Aspekte als z.B. großen Schub zu erreichen. Einmal reden wir hier von viel längeren Brenndauern, z.B. oder halt viele kleine Zündungen und dann halt Zündungen über Monate, Jahre hinweg, dass solche Triebwerke dann auch nach 10, 15 Jahren im Weltraum noch funktionieren. Und was ganz besonders wichtig ist, bei den ganz kleinen Triebwerken, die jetzt für die Lageregelung des Satelliten eingesetzt werden, dass der Satellit sich drehen kann in alle möglichen Richtungen, da muss man dann ganz genau den Schub dosieren können. Das heißt, da darf dann, wenn so ein Triebwerk nur einen Newton Schub hat, muss dann, wenn das abgeschaltet wird, darf da auch wirklich kein Resttreibstoff mehr aus dem Triebwerk rauslaufen, was noch zu einem kleinen Zusatzschub führen würde, weil ich muss den Satelliten ja dann mit dem exakt gleichen Gegenschub wieder abbremsen, sonst würde er sich ja irgendwie weiter drehen, entweder in die eine oder andere Richtung. Und wenn ich nicht mit dem anderen Triebwerk in die andere Richtung exakt den gleichen Schub wieder hinkriege, wie bei der ersten Zündung mit dem anderen Triebwerk, dreht er sich irgendwie und bleibt nicht stehen in der neuen Position. Und das ist die Herausforderung bei diesen Triebwerken.
Also während bei den großen Raketen, da geht es eigentlich immer so ums Maximum. Man schaltet da irgendwie mal ein Feststoffrakete und das brennt dann einfach ab wie so ein Feuerwerk. Und hier haben wir das Gefühl, da sitzen halt so kleine Zwerge mit Strohhalmen im Mund, die dann so in jede Richtung machen, um ein bisschen zu halten.
Kleine Impulse, die wirklich exakt getrimmt sein müssen.
Ist das hier auch ein Thema beim DLR in Lampoldshausen?
Die Triebwerke, die wir hier testen, die kleinsten, das ist bei unserem Prüfstand P10, das sind dann diese sogenannten Apogäumstriebwerke. Wie ich vorhin schon mal gesagt hab, wenn die Rakete den Satelliten aussetzt, ist das in die sogenannte geostationäre Transferbahn oder geostationären Transferorbit. Der Satellit kommt mit dem eigenen Schwung, mit der eigenen Geschwindigkeit dann bis auf 36.000 Kilometer Höhe und muss dann dort oben nochmal sein eigenes Triebwerk zünden, um dort oben zu bleiben. Und das sind solche Triebwerke, die normalerweise so 400 Newton, also 40 Kilogramm Schub haben.
Welche Technik kommt da zum Einsatz?
Das ist auch wieder, weil man es sicherer machen will vom Einsatz her, diese selbst zündenden Treibstoffe mit Hydrozyne und Stickstofftetroxid.
Die einfach zuverlässig immer wieder zünden. Genau.
Solche Triebwerke benutzt man zum Beispiel auch bei Raumsonden. Wenn man zum Beispiel an die Cassini-Raumsonde denkt oder an die Galileo-Raumsonde zum Saturn oder zum Jupiter, benutzt man auch solche Triebwerke dann zum Einschießen in die Umlaufbahn um diese Planeten und das kann man auch nochmal als Beispiel nehmen. Gerade bei der Galileo-Raumsonde zum Jupiter, da wurde das Triebwerk auch hier beim DLR getestet. Die Sonde konnte dann nicht zum üblichen Zeitpunkt starten, weil sie mit dem Shuttle gestartet werden sollte. Das war ein halbes Jahr vorher genau die Challenger-Explosion. Musste dann wieder noch drei, vier Jahre am Boden stehen, bevor es dann gestartet werden konnte. Und so hat man dann ein Triebwerk, das man hier getestet hat, was dann ein paar Jahre noch auf der Erde stand und dann fünf Jahre durch den Weltraum geflogen ist und musste dann nach zehn Jahren oder so beim Jupiter einwandfrei funktionieren. Und da muss ich auch immer sagen, das ist alles nicht selbstverständlich. Stellen Sie mal ein Auto in die Garage und lassen es mal zehn Jahre stehen, ob es dann noch anstrengt.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Das ist echt eine Herausforderung. Was ist denn so mit neuen, ganz neuartigen Antriebssystemen, die hier wahrscheinlich jetzt keine Rolle spielen, der Ionenantrieb zum Beispiel?
Da weiß ich jetzt nichts drüber.
Also das betrifft ihn jetzt hier sozusagen diesen Standort überhaupt nicht. Aber auch neuartige Antriebssysteme werden getestet, sind im Einsatz.
Also bei uns geht es ganz konkret um diese chemischen Raketenantriebe, weil egal, ob man jetzt über Ionenantriebe spricht, das sind ja im Moment üblicherweise Triebwerke mit wenigem Schub, aber die man auch über Jahre hinweg laufen lassen kann. Das sind eher Triebwerke, die man dann im Sonnensystem... Ich glaube, man kann das System für Raumsonden gebrauchen, wo es dann aber auch auf die Flugzeiten nicht ankommt, wo man dann wirklich längere Zeiten in Anspruch nehmen kann. Aber um von der Erde abzuheben, wird man immer diese chemischen Raketenantriebe brauchen, bin ich der Meinung, weil man halt erstmal die Erdanziehungskraft überwinden muss.
Und dafür, da hilft einfach nur Power.
Da hilft einfach nur Power, richtig.
Ja, super. Ralf, haben wir denn irgendwas ganz wichtiges vergessen zu erwähnen? Ich glaube, wir haben hier schon einen gewaltmarschigen Durchgang durch die Technik gemacht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das war, glaube ich, ziemlich ein Rundumschlag.
Ja, schön. Das soll das ja hier auch sein. Vielen Dank für die Ausführung.
Gerne.
Und ja, auch vielen Dank fürs Zuhören bei dieser Ausgabe, die ein bisschen länger geworden ist. Aber wir wollen ja hier auf keine Details verzichten. Und ich finde das ein sehr spannenden Durchmarsch hier. Ein ganz anderes Bild hier zum Kopf, wenn ich jetzt startende Raketen mir vorstelle. Da greift dann das eine in das andere. Ja, und das war's mit dieser Ausgabe, der dritten von Raumzeit. Und würde mich freuen, wenn ihr auch beim nächsten Mal wieder einschaltet und sage Tschüss und bis bald.